two it is I banished Ethan yet again
punished Ethan punished Ethan huh from
now on the only Elon Musk that exists to
me is
I wish he owned Twitter
yeah so guys uh welcome to H3 podcast it
is Monday I'm actually really happy to
be back here doing a live show
thank you guys
thank you we actually yes thank you love
the enthusiasm thank you wow
more intensity Dan
thank you bro thank you
yeah I appreciate that uh today we're
sponsored by Babel thank you we love
them uh God bless them I'm excited guys
because last week was a weird week we
came back from our YouTube suspension
now we're getting into all kinds of
trouble yeah we are oh yeah we yeah we
well right it's me but if yeah but if
but uh you guys are incentivized to
babysit me because y'all are going to be
losing a job here pretty soon that's
right yeah
no I'm just kidding I saw I saw a post
on the subreddit with like 5 000
points maybe you guys can pull it up
where it's like you guys all know uh
that this show is gonna get permanently
banned it's just a matter of time I'm
like man
ye of little faith fools I mean what
would give them that idea
listen I've been doing this for 10 years
okay I get you get strikes here and
there but I know what I'm doing that's
true I'm not going to get permanently
banned you're definitely gonna get
banned on Tick Tock today though that's
for sure oh well that you can count on
that every day that's a daily occurrence
yeah here four thousand this show will
eventually be permanently banned and you
know what come on guys come on man I've
essentially been banned from Twitter
Twitter's a rattle oh
no I'm not gonna get banned guys don't
worry I I look I am an idiot that'll
Grant you
but we had a strike and I'm a I can be a
good boy for three months
and I'll be honest I was I get a little
brazy when I don't have a strike
because you can you can let your hair
down and say stuff like bench beer
should be the first
[Music]
I think I was gonna say I said he should
be the first to join me for Hanukkah
dinner that's very sweet that's a very
nice
across the aisle like that yeah potato
latkes
[Music]
oh God haga Sophia
[Laughter]
you know the kagano Sophia
Ave Maria
h
whoa what's love doing
he's going through a phase yo he's in
his right now let's put the um what's
with the hair sticks it's uh the new
Antboy cosplay
is that hair or yeah it's just hair it's
my aunt antennas gosh
okay we'd love to see it don't hey he
looks fly as [ __ ] dude I didn't I wasn't
hating damn [ __ ] I didn't say a peep
about it
anyway yeah guys don't worry I'm not
gonna get suspended okay you know I get
in trouble here and there I make
calculated risk but don't worry I'm
we're not going anywhere this show is
forever
okay
thank you thank you for being here yeah
but I was gonna say this is we're
finally back to making our live shows
like usual last week was kind of weird
and we had a bunch of um guests which
just kind of happened uh serendipitously
we were scheduling them all and they all
just kind of converged on that one week
don't worry but uh boy we have an insane
show here today
um actually we have a special guest uh I
don't know if she's gonna be here the
whole time but Jessenia from Bachelor
world famous bachelor wow Bachelor
royalty here in the building that's
right so nice to have you here
um we did a photo shoot for Teddy fresh
that was so nice of you you're in town
for the or can you say for a week yeah
I'll be I'll be leaving the ninth I came
down to film The Reunion yeah I hope you
gave those dogs hell
no I'm okay I'm happy this is a little
unplanned but I'm so happy to go ahead
and hang out with you guys yeah and
maybe we can do an interview you off
contract yeah she's going to spell the
TV
let's go and also we are joined by uh
another Jess uh I don't you're oh you
are mic'd up but you're not cameraed up
Jess is our everybody's hair stylist you
do ela's hair yeah and Sam's hair anyone
else's
did you do that brilliant red color of
Sam's wow people have been losing
they're mine over that red yeah so so
the reason that Jess is here uh the
Beloved hair uh queen of of issue
podcast is that I was tossed The
Gauntlet by Ela
she said to me we should straighten your
hair and make it into two perfect spiky
mohawks and I said there's no shot in
hell
you can straighten my hair and do that
it's just impossible my hair growing my
hair back it's not gonna do it but then
Ela talked to Sam and Olivia and she
said not only can we do it
I guarantee we can do it and then they
got Jess involved and if I lose though
it's because of Jess because she is a
hair she's a hair doc I mean yeah she's
in the lab doing hair all the time but I
don't know man I don't think you can do
it we got this you think you can
straighten it yeah for sure
so we're going to be doing that today
that's the segment we're doing
that's going to be fun thank you for
being here it'd be really fun
um
but obviously at the top of the show
I'll be talking about my
uh Twitter uh permanent suspension over
the uh the fragile ego of the richest
man in the world hi
it's incredible well not him he's a
winner Elon ma money hi wait we gotta
people maybe some people don't know what
we're talking about
Elon Ma
this is the only
Elon ma here I just pulled it up his
name is yilong ma
he's the man bro hi everyone
how does music [ __ ] [ __ ]
hi hi
uh I love when he does these videos it
seems like he has no plan at all
he just goes out goes ha I'm Elon
uh money zero planning just start
rolling and I'll figure it out which is
kind of similar to elon's Plan than
buying Twitter it's a good uh commentary
there thank you thank you yeah so I've
been permanently banned on Twitter
thank you thank you everybody yes yes
yes
thank you
um
here's what happened last night
Twitter's a rat hole Twitter's a [ __ ]
Rat Hole oh by the way I wanted to say
quickly at the top we brought back I I
had to tape this because I don't know
YouTube's a little you never know with
YouTube Elon Musk is a piece of [ __ ] a
fan favorite
an original design by moi
we brought it back for the limited time
only to celebrate my Twitter uh permit
ban and to say Elon Musk is a giant
piece of [ __ ] and it's incredible how
you can be worth 200 billion dollars and
still be such a loser
yeah right I mean why Twitter is insane
it's kind of crazy Twitter's a [ __ ]
rap insane
um so go to teddyfresh.com it should be
right there at the top this is going to
be a pre-sale you can only get it now
and never again uh well y'all have a
week to buy it and then we're just gonna
basically
ship them out
and uh that's that so Elon Musk is a
piece of [ __ ] guys let him know
it's actually a fire shirt dude I know
like it is kind of fire do you wear that
around I love I know you said you would
yeah no I've been I've been wearing it I
wish we wish I knew I we were gonna
probably promote it today but I've been
wearing it all the time yeah I had to
pull this out of the closet for today I
um
I love it yeah so what happened okay all
right okay all right
oh we also have this Teddy fresh thing
should we do that maybe at 50 we made a
Teddy fresh promo us and the crew that
video I wanted to watch that we put it
on oh yeah I wanted to talk about that
because okay perfect
what's the problem
no we have to play it first I think well
we record I play it first in the room
and we'll talk about okay I'll pull it
up I'll just pull it up on that today
yeah so uh we shot this
um
and I think it came out really good I
thought it was really fun and thank you
guys all about by the way for
participating
um this was promoting the new November
collection okay here it is Dan has
thought so go ahead mwah and the tie-dye
velor jacket my goodness this thing is
so beautiful it's classy it's gorgeous
you hear the beat You Feel The Beat
yes the base levels are even higher in
this velor tie-dye jacket okay turn it
up boom open it wait you want we I know
we have a full screen version but
what could you possibly have it's The
Full Experience you don't get it unless
you see the full thing
okay I don't have it in my doctor it's
in the dock yeah right here crew Teddy
fresh
okay so oh thank you so we're gonna
watch the whole doc on
the director's cut and the tie-dye the
Lord my goodness oh my God all right so
it's important Dan has a problem
apparently I didn't know that okay here
is moi and the tie dye the Lord jacket
Mike did I do something wrong then
it to me what the [ __ ] did I do see it's
gorgeous
just listen You Feel The Beat
the base levels are even higher in this
velor tie-dye jacket okay turn it up
boom open it
it's hot
it's spicy
you're gonna look good you're gonna feel
even better you know what it is what did
I do uh-huh it's next oh it's nothing's
happened yet oh damn for Dan joining us
with the color block long sleeve oh Dan
has never looked good here comes Ian
okay that that
all right
all right Dan first of all I meant to
say Dan has never looked better
somehow that came out of my mouth oh
Freudian slip and let me also say who
who edited this maybe because I did a
take again the right way and for
whatever reason a b decided to keep that
one again no go ahead Dan but the
reality is that
everybody was expecting me to say that
was the issue that's kind of funny my
bigger issue was that we shot that for
the podcast in the context of the
podcast where you play it back and it's
like oh it's goofy this is fun this is
fun little goofy thing the crew do this
fake photo shoot when you post it on the
actual Teddy fresh socials Suddenly It's
like a real video yeah I didn't sign up
for that I'm not a [ __ ] model okay
how dare you well first of all first of
all I was shooting this and you
definitely our natural kid oh so wait
are you are you mad at me for like uh uh
I'm just saying I I I didn't sign up
your day rate I didn't sign up to be a
Teddy French model okay well you kind of
did that'd be the most fun you kind of
did okay a few things so rude a few
things one you know I shot and recorded
that I had an hour to edit that to
record and edit that and it came out
great we didn't expect it did that good
that's why we shared it first of all
second of all no but uh yeah you did
record a second take Ethan but you also
said that you'd give me the final call
if I should leave it yeah I did no I did
I just I and by the way I think I'm glad
you did but I'm just saying Dan uh
really your your beef should be with a B
well listen if if that had just been
played on the podcast it would have been
all laughs and Goofs and it's like oh
Ethan always picking on Dan Dan the
hater
you Dan stop it okay you pick on me bro
yeah they say yeah they say you pick on
him we love him I'm bullying you yeah I
get bullied every day from Dan yeah I
still employ him imagine that
um
well what happened was we filmed it for
Friday and then Avi Loeb the uh
astrophysicist came on
and um
I was like I'm not gonna run this middle
inappropriate I had about black holes
talking about black holes so I said you
know let's just put it up but you know
what I'll consult you next time Dan and
I'll make sure that it's all my agent
yeah exactly put us in touch yeah who's
uh manager are you Steve Rossi yeah
Steve Rossi has signed up he's didn't
such a stellar job with Jimmy Lee that I
felt like you know I had to get a piece
of that yo I'm confused I have them
stream open it doesn't show the live
stream numbers did they change something
you don't know oh no there it is oh they
do they just changed it oh yeah the UI
changed I put it in the last couple
weeks okay anyway let's there it is I
don't want to shortchange uh Ian who's
who has looked
who has never looked better unlike Dan
who's never looked good at all
look good here comes Ian with the doodle
corduroy jacket I might be making up the
names here but corduroy uh that one
looks really good Zach is working it
working it this one is the reverse
fleece Amy looking very gosling-esque
today cam is in the teddy bear hoodie
ears hat um some of these names are not
correct just go to the website
teddyfresh.com and you'll you'll see him
there okay Sam working in this is the
first time
wow unisex by the way but it fits
everybody happily thank you ladies yeah
off stage ab's now back they're thinking
they're doing it it's teddyfresh.com we
love it everybody looks so freaking good
today there it is the Beautiful cast we
have and damn it's teddyfresh.com isn't
a place to
thank you guys thank you Evan for
participating except Dan who apparently
is shaking me down at this moment but
that's okay yeah
um
also I guess did you put this in my dock
here's some here's some actual models uh
no offense of course
yeah some nice shots of the products
here you guys get it you guys get it you
guys get it you guys get it you guys get
it that's a lot of images okay thank you
all right
oh Ela I did say that it was pre-sale
Ela says clarify Elon Musk shirt is
pre-sale thank you thank you peace and
love there's a serious message it's a
pre-sale thank you thank you
all right so let's get to the uh what
everybody's waiting to hear about so and
then we can get into the hair segment
sorry to keep you waiting just I got
banned last night so it's kind of
breaking news you know what I mean you
know gotta talk about this crap
yeah so Elon Musk bought uh
dude should we watch the clip of us
talking about him first I think that
maybe is a good way to kick it off
because months ago when it was first
announced that Elon Musk
hey was gonna buy Twitter
we had a very prophetic
take I think on this whole situation we
said
it was going to basically ruin his life
it's a lose-lose
and um he's going to be taking one of
the biggest L's in human history it's
got to be right 44 billion
just for everyone to hate you where's
that clip uh let's see I'm grabbing it
right now oh thank you yeah you can't
keep getting away with it yeah
apparently I wasn't the only one who got
banned Kathy Griffin got banned and I'll
be say this
she got actually she got temporary band
I'm the only idiot that got Sarah
Silverman also did it she got a
temporary band she's back now yeah Sarah
Silverman's back did cat I don't know
that Kathy got permanently banned only
me and I'm the only one by the way who
had parody
in the header and the description
um and yet here I am permanently banned
here's us now here's us predicting you
can call me Nostra Thomas
yeah I was trying to think I was trying
to think of a funny little play on
gotcha gotcha yeah
nostradangus
um anyone pretty good that's pretty good
thank you somebody's
no nostrad Duncan on Elon yeah
pretty good thank you everybody all
right here it is putting himself in a
lose-lose situation everyone loves him
now
mark my words no not everyone but like
especially within like April or May I
think there's a lot of people in the
middle too who are like we love you hold
on I have a breaking uh I have a
Breaking of a setup here Nostra Deez
Nuts yo
thank you
thank you thank you unbelievable mark my
words
you cannot own Twitter and be loved and
be beloved you just became a mod and
everybody hates Moss
except our mods we love our mods oh
Ahmad he became a mod but you know
that's the stereotype is like the the
mods suck [ __ ] the mods or whatever and
everyone's a mod now he just he [ __ ]
himself so bad by buying Twitter he flew
too close to the Sun the guy feels
Invincible everyone is going to hate his
guts in a year or two because Twitter
is around some regulation otherwise it
turns into a cesspool
and everybody is going to justly or
unjustly blame him for whatever's
happening
let's say Marjorie Taylor green
marjor and Taylor green post you know
the most obscene like an image of like a
dead as a dead
Muslim person just something that's like
so beyond the pale
Twitter's gonna remove it rightfully so
this is what's interesting is that
basically happened with Kanye yeah he's
just went on these crazy anti-Semitic
I could literally say anti-semitic [ __ ]
and they can't drop me
that proved to be wrong buddy oops now
uh now uh now what
the president by the way am I TR am I I
think I'm on trending on Twitter now
because I think they removed me
yesterday after it happened but uh
yeah for for me I see it's number one
Ethan Klein earlier was h3h3 yeah me too
so let's see what can we encourage
people to we say justice for Ethan Klein
comedy is dead
nah that's cringe
yeah that's the point isn't it
how about the
yilong ma for CEO of Twitter see that's
one here
elong ma Supremacy and then the
conservatives they turn it into a whole
new thing where whatever happened is no
longer what you really lost weight
thanks bro
definitely notice it
thanks bro I had a bad weekend though
and I had a cheat weekend but I got to
get my [ __ ] back together this week but
thank you bro
thank you so much for noticing
it's become a I'm just saying he he
whatever goes wrong on Twitter now he's
gonna be the blame there's always going
to [ __ ] go wrong on Twitter he just
[ __ ] himself big time with this yeah
you staked out this position where he
explicitly says that he is a free speech
absolutist an absolutist that will not
hold true that's proven not to be true
and even in my dumbass case where I was
simply making Goofs about him and um
this whole week has actually been pretty
fun on Twitter the probably the funnest
I've had on Twitter just because my
whole timeline is like 90 people dunking
absolutely dunking on Elon uh he's such
a tool he's such an idiot and a such a
[ __ ] loser
[Music]
um
it's just it's just incredible and even
you know remember when you walked into
Twitter with the sink
for like the dumbest joke ever let it
sink in
so now people are posting I'm gonna sink
this company which makes way more sense
oh
what a weird like who told him to do
that you went and bought a sink bro
which is so weird he has like some kind
of a group chat I remember him
mentioning that in some clip he has some
kind of a weird boomer me group chat and
I think everything like literally the
whole downfall of Twitter is because of
that uh
one Facebook Boomer page ended the whole
social media ha
here imagine this
[Music]
you can't be serious
ly
[Laughter]
dude that was [ __ ] dumb as hell
just imagine he sent somebody to like
Kohl's
Saint bruh for this joke what do you who
you cared top you prop comic now [ __ ]
all right Elon yes so anyway here's what
happened
um by the way I know people are gonna be
like oh sure Ethan but I was thinking of
quitting Twitter anyway I [ __ ] have
continued to hate Twitter more and more
and every minute I spend on there is
literally
[Music]
I'm like paying for death
like I'm literally taking and shaving
hours and days off my life being on
Twitter
and when I'm dead and in the [ __ ]
ground
um all the lot my last thought will be I
should have spent less time on Twitter
a thought experiment
I did a thought experiment
Twitter's a [ __ ] Rat Hole
what rules you sons of [ __ ] no
hit me with the what rules
what rules you sons of [ __ ] what
rules you sons of [ __ ] you sons of
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what
rules
sons of [ __ ] Twitter's a rat hole
Rat Hole
Twitter's a raffle rats will dance for
money if you pay them
what the [ __ ] was that
rats will dance for money if you pay
them for money if you pay them
I did not [ __ ] my dog
I did not have sexual
you're stupid bad dog
uh yeah I think and I think you're right
uh I think there's video evidence of me
saying that yeah I'm almost positive
there is so so any all the haters saying
oh sure uh masks smiling but crying
underneath
nah dude hi it may sound like opium but
it's not it's legit we also
obviously you knew that was gonna happen
yeah I I knew I was going to get banned
yeah and that was kind of the point why
I thought it was such a fun experiment
because so Elon makes this great
Proclamation
first of all my favorite he goes comedy
is
what do you say when he bought Twitter
comedy's legal now comedy is legal now
right he said that
can you guys pull these tweets up as I
reference them sure yeah so he comes
into Twitter headquarters says comedy is
legal now oh everybody
take a breath a sire relief finally
around the world comedy is legal again
[ __ ] you legalize comedy so you
could bring a sink into HQ
44 billion dollars comedy is now legal
on Twitter oh my God thank you thank you
oh go then fast forward
two days or something I think it's like
six days he goes going forward any
Twitter handle engaging in impersonation
without clearly specifying parody will
be permanently suspended
by the way another funny thing is that
when he came in he said we're
re-examining all permanent suspensions I
don't believe anyone should be
permanently suspended he also tweeted
that
[Music]
and now here I'm suspended for dunking
on dumbass sink carrying [ __ ] boy
Elon Ma
yeah so um
can you find that tweet because it is
quite ironic uh thank you for the gifted
Bella thank you
hello hello
[Music]
um
so
apparently Sarah Silverman also got uh
she got back she got she's back right
yeah Sarah's back she said I'm a free
speech absolutist and I Duty for
breakfast every day that's what she said
and she changed her name to Elon and she
had his logo and she got suspended for a
week for that
uh
I thought comedy was back bro
comedy is back
damn
seems like comedy had more freedom
before Elon bought Twitter though
at least in my experience and Sarah's
yeah but she's back
uh Griffin said
she you know Elon Musk can't figure even
said after much spirited discussion with
the females in my life I've decided that
floating blue is for their choice for
their choices only right
so
a light goof I mean I really like goof
nothing like what I tweeted out
but that's what freedom speech is right
like it doesn't matter what people say
you defend it regardless that's
absolutist and absolutely that's his
term
and absolutist is like let's post
Gore let's post like pedophilia that's
like no exception absolutist
no but like the the uh concept of free
speech of course isn't about speech that
you agree with you know that then you
got no problem there you're but it's
about how you treat speech you don't
agree with that's like the whole [ __ ]
idea
because that's when it's a problem
uh so she got was she permanently
suspended or is she back she's not back
yet
yeah because on mine
if you go to her Twitter does it say
temporarily or permanently because mine
says permanent I got
I got got big time they got you oh yeah
account suspended Twitter spends
accounts that violates Twitter rules
that's it so if you go to mind what does
it say does it say the same thing
uh
yours has account suspended that's the
same thing
well anyway when I saw Elon tweet this I
was like oh dude this is awesome like
this is [ __ ] awesome just a week ago
he's talking about how comedy's back
comedy's legal again and then now he's
talking about how I'm gonna be
permanently Banning people
who don't Eva had a really funny point
she's like what do you want you need
like uh Twitter handles are gonna end up
like 2015 YouTube pranksters like gone
wrong gun sexual parody prank yeah it's
a prank bro also you need if it's that
easy to impersonate someone I think the
problem is with the platform
right they could just make it the
verified accounts can't change their
name that's easy done exactly like why
the [ __ ] are you gonna give me the tools
to do this goof and then permanently ban
me for it
um also he said that if verified users
changed their name they'd lose their
verified Mark and so I said okay cool
I'm gonna change my name and lose my
verified Mark for the for the laugh
and I I didn't lose it it's like the
guy's just making [ __ ] up as he goes I
mean clearly
so I said okay I'm gonna I'm gonna make
my account a makeover
let me show what it looked like first
what I did is
um
I'm trying to find my banner
yeah they're in this album okay so
here's first thing I did
is I made this my header parity account
I just drew it on my phone I said look I
just want to be clear in the info it
says parody account okay
and then the header it says parity
account and under tweet under every
tweet I said it's a parity account it's
in my info and editor
so as far as I'm aware as far as what he
wrote out I satisfied his rules of clear
his rules what road rules you son of a
[ __ ]
I satisfied his requirement no I think
he needed to have it in the handle he
did not specify that and as far as I'm
aware bro I said parody and the [ __ ]
header in the info and under every uh
every goddamn tweet I said it's a parody
guys it's a goddamn parody here's the
xhax3 podcast by the way
looks great
Elon has had some pretty [ __ ] up
haircuts he might actually sport that a
did you photoshop like his cheeks at all
that is on Photoshop this cheeks whoa
crazy looking they match the melting on
Ethan's hair
it's the same direction what about his
hair color did you change his hair color
I might have touched that a little bit
just to make it nice to make it pop yeah
wow good love the attention to details
so I I said look I've satisfied I read
his tweet and I said I've satisfied
my requirements
I'm pretty sure in the terms of service
it probably says it in the like in the
more official thing
well he said before we would just
suspend them
but now now that the Free Speech
absolutions came in uh were permanently
Banning them no questions asked and I
don't know I disagree Dan I think I met
I mean I'm not I didn't go through the
terms of service and read it but I I as
far as I wear as I look I I even his
tweet he says handle he specifically
says handle what the [ __ ] does handle is
your display name pull it up
uh you just had it up a second ago uh
it's the one where he says starting
immediately blah blah blah or
permanently banned Twitter
we need to do a poll to find out if
people think that I was
clearly labeled he says clearly labeled
as a parody account now I don't know
what more
I can do and now I'm and now I'm
creating fomo off of Twitter and it's
their loss
hmm
where's this damn tweet I sent it in
Discord oh okay yeah uh but now we
really have Western in the morning
here I pulled it up here it is he said
previously we issued a warning before
suspension but now we're rolling out a
widespread verification will be no
warning above it go up one tweet going
forward any Twitter handles and Gates
Twitter accounts that just means Twitter
account the handle is the handle my dude
no a Twitter account that's how you
refer to a Twitter account a Twitter
handle what that's it that that doesn't
mean you're a [ __ ] tweet at and again
if there's a failing of of understanding
it's on the platform side bro yeah
regardlessness of the Twitter
organization like also it just underlies
how [ __ ] dumb his whole plan is he
goes we are going to democratize
verification
okay
and also anyone who starts impersonating
is going to be permanently banned
because we have no way of verifying
people anymore right because everyone
can buy verification oops
Free Speech within this very strict
guideline free speech for eight dollars
a month yeah that's premium speech can
we do a poll I want to know if people
think I was clearly labeled as a parity
account
or not I mean sure I'll do a poll yeah
to be clear I mean I I don't think it
really matters either way because
obviously he's just gonna ban whoever he
wants which frankly is why point it's
his prerogative he owns Twitter you can
ban whoever the [ __ ] he wants but yeah
they're the ones that are always yeah
exactly that's the point I was trying to
make bro he's not a free speech
absolutist he's a [ __ ] petty little
goon who literally spends all of his
time on Twitter this guy's eight kids
and like 20 companies and this man
spends [ __ ] 20 hours a day on Twitter
it's embarrassing stop
uh was Ethan's accounts needed a bad bro
was Ethan's account what I don't know
how to word this it wasn't was my was
Ethan's a clown account clown a clown
tan sorry 40 and slip he was he was
Rayleigh clown as Jordan Peterson once
called you Dan has never looked good
was Ethan's account uh clearly the
artist parody labeled as parody yes or
no
ask your community
not in the community right obviously my
point was like dude he's definitely
gonna ban me I'm gonna do exactly like
he says and he's definitely gonna ban me
because he's a petty little [ __ ] and so
that was kind of my thing going forward
and I had like I was like 90 sure I was
gonna get you know banned going into
this
and I just wanted to enjoy the ride but
um so I'll show you guys what went down
I mean 82 yes and by the way I'll say
usually when media reports on my
mishaps
I feel like they are always covering it
like well Ethan's a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] and he really [ __ ] up like they
never giving me the benefit of the doubt
but this is one of the only times
when the media is covering it and it's
like Ethan had clearly uh displayed that
he was a parody account and still got
banned thank you
Philly D don't [ __ ] me on this one bro
did he put out his facility yeah
oh
okay so let's read the tweets it says
okay let's go let's go for it bro I went
out guns blazing okay so here's my wait
this isn't it
so he says okay here we go and by the
way it's not even his new logo it's his
old Avatar
I said and maybe this one just seems a
little too real maybe that's why it
upset him even though Jeffrey Epstein
committed horrible crimes I do still
miss him on nights like this for his
warmth and camaraderie rest in peace old
friend
and I think too many people thought that
might be real huh but then I sit right
under it let it be known it's a parody
account
it's right there in the info free but
before Free Speech dies comedy lives
forever hashtag free G Lane
yeah I had so much fun you guys I hope
you know how much fun we were cracking
up I was like oh it was the best time
I've ever had on Twitter it was just so
much fun
yeah it was so good here's my banner I
drew that I don't know if you guys would
believe this but I actually made that on
my phone
yeah
mm-hmm very nice then I went on I said
listen G Lane Maxwell is an extremely
decent woman who have had the pleasure
of meeting several years ago and that's
true there's a picture of them together
maybe you can pull that up yeah
by the way guys Elon Musk is a piece of
[ __ ] shirt is available for a limited
time at teddyfresh.com get yours today
thank you this is tape it says [ __ ]
under the tablet yeah so they're old
friends and look how happy he is to be
there and her especially hi not that's
not elongma he would never he would
never so he says she said Elon Muska
Bizarro Elon Musk says she's extremely
decent woman had the pleasure meeting
several years ago it's a shame how she's
been demonized and ran over by the Press
hashtag free EEG
jizzling no I don't think it's jizzling
I think it's no it's not actually just
lame but I like Elaine
and everybody says parody accounts in my
info and header [ __ ]
okay this one
this one I was getting a little creative
with
I said Tesla autopilot is only
responsible for six accidental deaths
that sounds bad but when compared to how
many people die of car accidents it's
really not that serious that's funny
because he actually says [ __ ] like that
yeah I mean that one's fairly believable
saying
I just like the idea of him saying
explicitly
that six accidental deaths was not that
serious
very funny I mean come on work with me
and then there's this one
um yes I could have ended World Hunger
instead of buying Twitter but people
don't understand the importance of
having a free and open Forum if somebody
dies of starvation in Sudan it won't
affect the world but being able to say
the n-word on Twitter is a right we all
deserve
foreign
and I think that's right on I mean you
know so it's in essence he should be
thanking me I'm doing PR for him the
the air
that's Trump idiot
this was another one
uh people are gonna say the n-word on
Twitter that's a sacrifice I'm willing
to accept for the cause of free speech
that's funny
he's a white guy he's willing to accept
that work with me someone made a good
point that if they forced you to change
your name back that's gonna be an
awkward tweet yeah but that's true
but I was never gonna change I said I
was committed to being an Elon Musk
parity account for the rest of my days
on Twitter
all 30 minutes of them
and I would actually I was in the it was
fast too it was only like I already had
like an hour maybe
but this hell knows he's increasingly
Strange Days this one was popping off
dude the original
Jeffrey epsteemon and I was getting so
many [ __ ] followers during this time
I think everyone wanted to
tune in for the fireworks and see what
would happen
a bit of an old-timey joke there you
know thank you guys
um so
basically I was in the middle of writing
a really another Banger what was it I
don't remember but then I went to post
it and it said uh yeah you you can't
post you're gone you're gone again
you're gone
and it just explicitly said permanently
banned you know
so I don't know
once again Tim Poole uh friends of the
show another epic dub Tim pool look at
this wait I didn't see this you didn't
sir because what I like about Temple
when he defends me he doesn't add these
exceptions like
um
usually I wouldn't agree with him but or
or like uh yeah
this is dumb but I'm not going to shed a
tear for him [ __ ] like that right
absolutely
um it's like they when they want to have
their cake and eat it too be like well
I'm pro-free speech but I'm anti-ether
so I'm just gonna sit on the fence on
this one right all of it so Tim bull
said you can't be verified and be a
parody account it's in the rules
Elon actually changed the world to allow
it but only if you put parity in your
name yeah this isn't defending you at
all what the [ __ ] bro why'd you put this
one I saw him defending me yo [ __ ] you
pimple [ __ ] you [ __ ]
he's ruining everything
I saw one where he's defending me let me
see are you sure that wasn't from the
last band because [ __ ] you Temple hate
you idiot
being castrated
shout out Ken klipsenstein this guy's
awesome bro he's so funny
uh here's my tweet banger
account suspended there it is it's
historian two
it's a story in two in two images really
speaks for itself
um
also look at this Banger he posted today
he goes Twitter should
snack
to do this to independent-minded voters
shared power curbs the worst excesses of
both parties therefore I recommend
voting for a republican Congress given
that the presidency is democratic
sure
well he's got to throw a bone to his
followers because like we said they're
all getting worked up and kind of pissed
at him because he's not free speech
daddy like he promised he would be so I
don't know vote red or whatever who
cares
dude he's going down so bad right now
Howard Stern is trending what happened
radio jock uh Howard Stern urges
Americans to vote Democrat I mean
obviously we all know that
that's not how's that breaking news he
says that all the time okay thank you
oh here's Tim defending me no no no no
no no no no I don't know where you got
this information I swear I read one
where he was like epic dub Temple
yeah they are so used to getting away
with breaking the rules they are shocked
it's being enforced against them now I'm
not shocked no one's shocked literally
just a joke bro it's literally just a
joke all the haters and people who are
like tap dancing thinking like this
they're so happy
they're like Ethan is always trying to
get people banned on Twitter and now
he's begging us to help him I'm like
none of that is true [ __ ] I'm not
begging I'm happy I'm gone Twitter's a
[ __ ] Rat Hole
Twitter's a rat hole
Twitter's a rat hole what rules you sons
of [ __ ]
yeah meanwhile he unbanned Kanye West
who was like what what Holocaust
elon's like cool you can come back
someone who goofed on me banned forever
now what
hey Here Comes wait yes this is it
this is it
he erased it he bitched out Temple
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
I don't think that's the way oh okay he
said this is dumb just lock the account
until they remove it that's still up
yeah it's still up I'm looking at it
well that's a dub
I think all right
though right
I love that all of a sudden these
conservatives are like massive like
Twitter TOS stands
that's the real irony that's that's what
[ __ ] drives me nuts is it's like this
has been a discourse for years now of
like oh they're stomping all over Free
Speech they're they're censoring us and
it's like no Twitter's they're a company
they're not obligated to defend your
first amendment rights that's not how it
works that's not what the first
amendment is they can ban you for any
reason that they deem is necessary and
you can disagree with those reasons and
that's fine but it it's not illegal it's
not censorship it's not a free speech
issue now it's flipped and he's Banning
people for TOs and you're already seeing
it's like well it's very clear in the
terms of service and they're using the
exact same argument it's like it just
shows you how disingenuous the entire
discourse has always been they don't
care about Free Speech they're just
saying that it's always just have been
about I don't want to be punished for
being a Nazi like that's it that really
is at the core of all this and um
yeah oh listen guys ultimately Twitter
has nothing to do with free speech
nothing yeah it's literally just like a
private company that's owned by one
[ __ ] insecure Loser yeah who's
Banning people that are goofing on him
that's what's happening but it has
nothing to do with free speech and I've
never said only jokingly said that my
free speech is being curtailed I think
it's just funny because he came and
bought this app and was like I'm a free
speed actual absolutist and um and uh
comedy's back again baby and I was like
okay well let's see and sure enough that
[ __ ] banned me in an hour
but yeah it has nothing to do with free
speech I'm right here talking to you
guys who've got 50 46 000 people
watching so what the [ __ ] are you
talking about it's nothing free speech
idiots
literally nothing
and even if I get banned everywhere I
can still go on the on the corner and uh
Heckle people there that's free speech
that is true and you probably will yeah
I'll get banned everyone you'll see me
in Times Square just living out of a box
and sermonizing I'll become a black
Israelite oh no no no no
now what they're always heckling people
in Times Square somebody said you can go
back to Myspace there you go Myspace now
Myspace is free speech Let's be clear
about that Tom is the only good
Silicon Valley CEO I know so it's
actually quite nice to see
um a lot of people talking about it and
people actually coming down on my side
so how about that except for [ __ ] Tim
bull
all of it
also right afterwards I was trending my
name was trending and I pretty sure he
removed it and I'm back on Twitter and I
don't see it maybe
it's I don't think you were ever on the
real trending it was the you know
there's there's the trending the 4u
trending which is like tailored by the
algorithm to your interest so I think
you know a b and Olivia said they saw
you on there earlier you're still there
you still see it okay yeah yeah all
right just watching my algorithms get
crushed
um we are
at uh 48 minutes I'm almost done and
then we'll do our ad and then do the the
hair segment thank you okay uh
okay let's just do that a little bit
more but thank you Babel we love you
Babble yes yes
[Music]
um Babble talk to me baby
if you're like me and there's a foreign
language that you regret not learning in
school it's never too late to start with
Babel oh I'll miss you Babble is the
language learning app what does that
mean Ian oh my sure
uh oh mister
wow did you learn that on Babel you bet
I did holies no you're so way higher
than France in this list so you guys are
so educated in Sweden
um love you every sweetest person I've
ever met has like insanely fluid fluent
English they're all super intelligent
and well educated it's pretty incredible
and they all take that
[Music]
do you find that to be true what I'm
saying
yeah no I think so we're pretty bad at
math oh really bad at math but we know
English I'm gonna hit you with some
arithmetic next time so I can really say
oh [ __ ] yeah activation on your last oh
[ __ ] same way I hate to say this but
same with the Norwegians and the and the
the Danish they're all very very smart
yeah yeah and all right and uh
love that about them the Danish not so
much but that's fine
yeah right
yeah okay so let's just blast through
this so we can move on
um
here's some articles let's see who's
this Chad is this a guy
he's a guy no that one I don't care
about Temple dub
there was a lot of
articles that were tweeting that had
like a ton of likes on it
oh about your band yeah yeah the pop one
yeah papa crave I believe it is yeah
the pop Holly Road reporter mentioned my
dumbass
one step away from variety my dude
you're in Brian Kavanaugh territory
Ryan's celebrating at home
that I'm off Twitter he's so happy thank
you thank you drive angry YouTuber Ethan
Klein co-host of the popular show h3h3
it's kind of wow exactly right on there
yeah close enough also had his personal
account suspended by Twitter for
impersonating musk after testing the new
policy Klein as musk had tweeted a joke
about the Billionaire's alleged
friendship with Jeffrey Epstein but made
sure to Market clearly that his tweets
were parodies and his account was a
parody by changing the bio and the
header
after client suspension the H3 show
tweeted out comedy is dead on Twitter
and Elon Musk killed it there you go
pop crave 128
000
likes thank you pop crave we'd love to
see it I'm craving some
pop crave we love them don't we damn
um
absolutely love them
yep
yes
there it is
I was mentioned on NBC News
Twitter suspends user for imitating Elon
Musk an early test of free speech stance
thank you I am a free I'm a martyr you
guys understand like how important it is
what I did like that's just what I'm
trying to drive home
martyred myself you're so important
because you know I I put myself on the
line wow 2.3 million followers I built
that up over 10 [ __ ] years damn you
know how much money I can make from just
like tweeting out crypto and [ __ ] from
that right probably true dude I can make
a million bucks if I just Shield crypto
from that Twitter account damn
but I I you know I said I I may not
agree with what you say but I will
defend to the right uh to the death your
right to say it I put my I said Give Me
Freedom or give me death
wow and that's who I that's just who I
am oh oh [ __ ] Philly D dropped it let's
watch Philly you better not [ __ ] me bro
all right Philly what did you say about
it
you're beautiful bastards welcome back
to the Philip DeFranco show buckle up
make sure you hit that like button and
let's just jump into the news starting
with Ethan Klein got nuked off the
internet again that's not what happened
that's not actually what happened really
that's not what happened yo look at the
title Ethan Klein nuked for more I love
the title what am I getting I'm getting
nuclear sadness from space now that's a
good title Ethan Ethan Klein nuked from
orbit oh yeah do you call me Elon Musk
what why am I in orbit he's like from
orbiting no that's not it all right
Philly we're just saying the new is the
one in fact in Philly really after
everything we've been through
a little over a week ago after Elon Musk
took over the platform he declared that
comedy is now legal on Twitter but he is
seemingly unveiled that he is not an
absolutist about that or that there
sometimes have to be limitations to that
rule specifically impersonations and a
key thing with this story is people
impersonating Elon Musk since his
takeover it's been a big trend for
verified people to change their name and
photo to Elon musk's and tweet something
absurd or out of character oh wait pause
that go back go back that tweet is so
[ __ ] funny bro there's nothing better
than waking up and enjoying a fresh
steaming cup of my own urine such a
Tangy way to start the day and Simon
typically proven to help brain cells
grow if you want to be like me drink
your own pee 300 000 likes that's
awesome what happened to him did he get
busted yeah hi he did yeah permanently
banned uh uh Chris Warcraft what a name
shout out just like me he died for the
cause account suspended bye-bye he died
for the cause brother yeah
you want more Phillips no yeah no I want
more Philly yeah here's the thing and
you may not expect it it makes complete
sense why these people were suspended
impersonation has always been against
Twitter's rules so it wasn't surprising
to see this happen he's going to go but
can you imagine a number of people that
were bad but including no he's going to
say but Ethan right right I'm baking he
said we're expecting this I mean even
Ethan's own fans were like he's going
for the band but for anyone that did
this and didn't expect to get banned I
got a beautiful book for you to buy the
week of Thanksgiving you'd have to
include that it has a parody account in
the bio and oh my God Philly I told you
no he's not [ __ ] you at all he's
right only one oh my God look at this
bro
he got Ethan a book that said stupid
stupid account yeah what the [ __ ]
and he called me fat yo Philly call you
fat he's he didn't betray you he says I
have my own orbit it's exactly like I
said You [ __ ]
slimy traitors [ __ ]
Billy we love you don't listen to him
who's we me and dance
hold on starkiller's not banned
let's you know before I go on my
godfather Tyrant Amy stop
don't make me bring up the [ __ ] yo AB
you want to get started with me it's at
the top of the dog you want me to bring
up thank you
bro you really want to go there
Mr clout with a capital
yeah exactly no we're not doing that yet
let me give Philly the chance to redeem
himself before I blow the warhorn
all right you want me to play yeah
itself and what people like Ethan put
parity account as a banner you put
parity in the bio the name was just Elon
Musk and actually on that note on Sunday
musk also took it a step further by
tweeting going forward any Twitter
handles engaging in impersonation
without clearly specifying parody will
be permanently suspended previously we
issued a warning before suspension but
now that we are rolling out widespread
verification there will be no warning
this will be clearly identified as a
condition for signing up to Twitter blue
and adding any name change at all will
cause temporary loss of everybody so
positive so Infinity you [ __ ] coward
[ __ ] stop easy I'm being I'm joking I
know I know serious but he did [ __ ] me
he did [ __ ] he didn't [ __ ] you at all
he's spitting facts right now he's
riding the fence bro and he's yeah you
guys this is the [ __ ] ultimate fence
writer Dan and I don't know why you're
why are you doing this there's no fence
he's right
you didn't put parody in the name yeah
our audience is not the end-all be-all
of the Twitter TOS they don't know I'm
not play it
so Ethan changed his name to Elon Musk
and joked about the increased use of the
n-word on the platform as well as a
tweet about musk missing Jeffrey Epstein
he got permanently suspended as well as
Kathy Griffin and now a growing number
of people because like I said it wasn't
just one or two people that were doing
this so you did had Ethan Klein
defending his tweets on tick tock not
saying it was a clear parody something
you haven't said it would be an
exception also around this time you had
Elon making jokes about the suspension
saying of Kathy Griffin she was actually
suspended for impersonating a comedian
but if she really wants her account back
she can have it for eight dollars well
yes you had people understanding or even
defending the bands you had a lot of
people using this as a way to attack
things at him like free speech includes
racism but not making fun of you but
here's the thing like I said I am not a
musk fan but I understand these
suspensions that said that is not where
the Elon Musk bullshittery ends today
but there's been a lot of dude he was
literally just Banning people
impersonating him I had it clearly
labeled
Dan I'm I'm demanding you downvote the
video
Dan
this is a loyalty Test download download
the video
did Philly betray Ethan yes or no
is that the poll the yeses have it right
now
Philly
I come to you in this time of need
when everybody has my back finally for
the first time
but you
you come to me on the day of my
great Liberation I know it was you
freedom
not only do you say I have my own orbit
you know I've been working very hard to
lose weight and you of all people should
understand
but now for you to come and say call me
don't be stupid stupid
you break my heart feeling deep
and now
I'm gonna have to take you out on the
lake
and teach you a little something about
loyalty
[Music]
Philly D betrayed me for the last time
do you understand
every time he covers me
he doesn't
[ __ ] go far enough to defend me
Dan what do you want Space Mountain stop
with the Scorpion chair and download the
[ __ ] video bro I'm just laying down
all right fine you're the boss thank you
Philly I love you but Ethan pays the
bills yes thank you the first down vote
you see that
wait is it really yes
everybody loves Philly
not me
and now you come to me
I've laid down my life for free speech
for comedy
and now you're gonna run a train over me
Philly's going to run a train on you
he's gonna run a train over me what's up
so over over
I'm [ __ ] believable
[Music]
yeah the next time Philly D gets
canceled I'll remember this
yeah he never does that's the joke it's
just my ass every week
oh my God I thought he'd have my back
okay Philly I see how it is
I see how it is
it's so funny that we were waiting for
him to drop this I thought
there it is the people have spoken
there's no loyalty
family we have a family how did he do
how did he not have your back in what
way well he certainly didn't have my
back at all when what way did he have my
back I mean he's reporting the news but
like what would your idea of having your
back be but that well you shouldn't have
been banned these team mentioned no
because he did a whole look I'm not I
don't want to give this perception that
I'm seriously upset before we engage in
this any further right it's just jokes I
know okay just want to make that clear
thank you family he's out of the family
I'll tell you that yeah so what I would
have liked to have seen is um
him saying that I did disclose uh in the
Pedder and the [ __ ] title and you
said that he pointed that out but then
he goes but then he offers me a book
called don't be stupid stupid how about
I buy you that book Dan and see how you
feel the people that thought that they
wouldn't get banned you knew you were
gonna get banned when you did it
so that's not referring to you he wasn't
calling you yeah Ian why are you making
me so small in the chair make me bigger
bro it's such pathetic right why are you
you're on Dan's side now making me tiny
in the chair
I mean it's to scale
it's who is nobody's that tall it's just
it's just weird why am I so short
oh come on you guys
give me some respect God damn dude you
see what you've done Phil you're
infecting my [ __ ] crew with this
disease
on his 40th birthday of all days it's
not no wait today's your birthday that's
what it's a big 4-0 that's what I heard
hit me with that happy there it is
no it's not my birthday
[Music]
42 right now yo oh my God
and many more guys it's not my birthday
my birthday's in June and I'm 37. 42 is
a big year that's a big one the meaning
of the universe guys I'm 37 stop and I'm
definitely not 42.
there's anyone at my back in this whole
building
cut it Zack
[Laughter]
this is all Philly D's fault Philly L
this is what I'm saying this is [ __ ]
really w
ow Billy's turning 35 today I heard I
feel like back before uh how old is he
he's uh 31 actually we just turned 31.
let me see how old this is looks great
for his age Benjamin Button situation
[ __ ] fantastic he's 14. he's 36.
36.
unfortunately I'm a year older than my
others are going to call them an old ass
[ __ ] loser but I can't do that
I mean he is
well you're six years older than him
yeah I'm a one
six
yeah do I need to teach you a arithmetic
too uh oh you're 42. so
no 37. no you're
candle say 42. yeah the candles
the candles we're on Twitter
people used to do that all the time and
they never got yes of course well people
not people I've seen people who had
parody and the header oh if you have
parody you're fine yeah exactly like
there's there's people that would
impersonate
like crazy [ __ ] but and when you click
their account the banner and header says
parody account right and that was like
all good
um so I don't know it's it's not that I
don't like his take where it's like well
he's basically like Elon Musk is [ __ ]
awesome he can't do anything wrong and
Ethan's a fat loser he said fat he said
I'm in orbit I don't know I I think you
might be misinterpreting what does orbit
mean because I have my own gravity like
a black hole okay the nuke was in orbit
you were down on the surface of the
planet that's what nuked from orbit
means some sort of military and
satellite installation full of nuclear
bombs that it dropped and by the way if
he's gonna use a tongue and cheeky title
like Ethan gets nuked from orbit he
better be [ __ ] having my back
you know what I mean because otherwise
it's like he's tap dancing on My Grave
you're right he basically he [ __ ] on
your ancestors Graves too
yeah yeah
he basically denied the Holocaust he
basically did do that yeah it's worse
than that he denied he denied the The
Maccabees beat the Greeks on Hanukkah
I don't know oh all right thank you Dan
Elon Musk if you're like me and you
think if Philadelphia sucks
buy this shirt Elon Musk is a piece of
[ __ ] I'm gonna make Philly Dia sure Elon
Musk rules and I love him and send him
that
teddyfresh.com limited time only uh Elon
Musk
I got some bad news by the way
what I can't find the remote to the
Scorpion chair so I'm kind of stuck like
this we're falling apart I just filled a
Gatorade all over my laptop wait I saw
you running without oh [ __ ] oh my God
it's amazing how much this small
Gatorade is it okay I think it's okay
can you turn it upside down maybe that's
what I do yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
haha
are you having a great day
yeah people are calling him Lily D and I
agree with that Lily L really it's a
whole different person
but also I just want to say tomorrow I
just want to say that I'm kidding
obviously uh Philly D's a friend of the
show I do think that um he's on elon's
payroll but uh but ultimately I'm not
that I knew I was gonna get banned and
uh I'm not mad
but yo can you remind me um Lena can you
remind me on Philly D's birthday I'm
sending him a [ __ ] book that book
don't be stupid stupid what's his
birthday okay yeah I got it or something
even worse than that
like how to [ __ ] make a YouTube video
for dummies
but
okay so we have work to do Lena let's
put together a whole care package for
Lily l
dear Lily L okay I'm on it
yeah I'm pissed
dumbass idiot thank you love the only
one who's got my back in this whole
building you better watch out for the
Highlight tomorrow dude it's coming down
on him yeah we should think of a good
title Philly D is on Elon Musk payroll
yeah feel the
Philly diesel white supremacist
Philly these nuts
they'll eat these nuts
is that too far no it's funny
no about about him being a white
supremacist oh
yeah
I am of course all right let's move on
we've talked about this enough so that's
the story I had a lot of fun doing it I
knew I was gonna get banned and uh I
don't care Twitter's a rat hole and I
wanted to leave it anyway and it was a
fun time doing it and despite what Dan
and Philly said I think it exposed the
hypocrisy of Elon Musk that's not
either of our opinions well it was kind
of Phil's
don't be stupid stupid you just said you
just said a second ago you knew you were
gonna get banned yeah he was saying
people that thought they wouldn't get
banned doing that before Elon Musk
bought it I would not have been banned
yeah that's fine but
that's not dude it's not the world we're
living in man we're living
bro stop
or maybe I put it another way you're a
bunch of [ __ ]
thank you Rudy Julian thank you for
clearing that up enough thank you guys
enough apparently the whole mainstream
media that has my back for once is wrong
and Dan is committed to me being wrong
in this situation thanks Dan for always
having my back read my stalwart
supporter through thick and thin good
and bad Dan has always has my [ __ ]
back wrong
Rat Hole all right let's move on we're
gonna do the straight start thank you
for waiting Jess
so um Let's do let's see if you guys can
straighten my hair what do you guys
think you want to get started on that
make it happen I need to pee actually
really bad
um do you need to set up here or am I
going to move there what's the plan no
you're going to do it at the table okay
it's right where you are so I'll be
right back I'm just going to pee and
then we'll we'll we'll get into the
straightening segment okay sounds good
our boy Ryan or Harvey says we'll miss
you on Twitter broken heart yeah shout
out the legend
Ethan says not Dan that's true
okay
Ethan heard that uh please wish Danielle
C happy happy birthday
happy birthday happy birthday
happy birthday happy birthday
happy happy what else we got here Dan
eat the chip eat the chip we're going to
talk about the chip don't worry we'll
get to the chip yeah yeah all I see is
just straight up spam on here so let's
get that over with
well people are I got bad news for
people it's not happening but we'll talk
about it later
50 from Bella wait Bella is one of our
uh one of our Saudi royalty right yeah
she is absolutely
Texas is bigger than France ha ha
just [ __ ] on France today my
goodness
what's happening over here so what you
spill Gatorade on there
a game or something else going on yeah
yeah just want a little Gatorade
did you put it in rice yet I did not put
in rice that's good advice
I kind of need it for the show that's
the thing but I shouldn't be using it
should probably turn it off
I do have excuse not to work then
you got Apple Care it's fine bro it's
fine you got AppleCare I do you'll be
good though thanks buddy but I have a
lot of important stuff on here
happy 73rd birthday by the way for Ethan
from Mark
thanks Mark that's not even true bro
you're right
what's that
yeah okay thank you thank you
gosh
foreign
my husband just told me he's gay cheated
on me and is kicking me out love you H3
you keep me going
Jesus Mickey remember for 28 months
Mickey that's
sending you love yeah sorry about that
I love
candy corns and I don't know I don't
care if you're single perhaps consider
getting on a bachelor oh there you go
from the backstory there you go
what did she say
that her she just found out her husband
uh was gay and cheating on her and then
he kicked her out and then kicked uh
kicked her out and then she segued right
into Lobby H3 that'll be a hell of a
storyline if she does go on The Bachelor
though okay
Mickey
you know what to do
Jessenia do you believe in The Bachelor
like do you believe the people there
yourself excluded are actually looking
for love
um from what I've come to find
throughout what three seasons now I
think that a good percentage are
probably there for love but it's very
obvious like from the get-go who's
really not there for love there's got to
be a lot of people are there for just
like
oh the exposure because yeah
also
they picked the bachelor Bachelorette
from the pool of people right who are
dating so there's that huge opportunity
there too too yeah I think I mean
anytime someone's been there and it's
been pretty be clear that they're there
to like be the lead they've for the most
part been exposed um yeah I love that
too ironic because most of them that do
want to be the lead never end up being
the lead anyway never it's so good I
love it oh this is Jessenia she is
Bachelor royalty she's sitting with us
today she was doing a Teddy fresh soup
Bachelor royalty she's here for the
reunion
and uh this is my
hi Elon Musk is a piece of [ __ ] shirt
that you can buy at teddyfresh.com for a
limited time
is there anyone you want to call out
Jessenia
um I'm saving that for the juicy
interview oh yeah
okay when is your contract end
um sometime early next year I'm thinking
it's March but I'm gonna confirm dude I
have so many questions about like
you obviously you can't answer but one
question how long are you there during
Paradise like how long are you gone so
in Paradise we filmed for a month and
then for the regular seasons like The
Bachelor Bachelorette it's two months
damn but so when I I was like these
people are leaving behind
in most cases they're full-time jobs
they got to pay you guys for that time
right so you don't get paid for a
bachelor Bachelorette but you
okay because you're already in the door
then yeah pretty much like you're saying
you're kind of considered like a
personality then on TV so of course like
that makes sense and there's so many
people on Bachelor there's like a good
dealing with people and yeah like you
said a lot of them do quit their jobs
all that stuff I got really lucky I work
you can get started just my boss's wife
happens to be a fan of the show so I got
it
oh there you go
um so how does this gonna work is uh Sam
or do you want to get involved in Olivia
or I mean Jess is I don't know what's
the plan here if Jess needs any help
we're here but okay she's approached I
got it my again it's kind of unfair that
you guys brought such a pro here like
because I thought Elin
Sam we're gonna do it but with peace and
love Jess I I think you're great at your
job but I don't think there's any shot
in hell you're getting a straight double
mohawk
how are you feeling 10 out of 10. she
says 10 out of 10 100 yeah oh you have a
you have a mic I forgot yeah
yeah so Jess um or Jessenia
um yeah I know I was just thinking so
the amount you get paid for Bachelor in
Paradise is it like a nice amount or it
could be more
um I think in some cases it could be
more but I mean I guess it's enough to
get you by for that one month that
you're not working that's good at least
do they pay some people more than other
people
um I don't know if I can say but that's
a yes I think that's pretty
self-explanatory
wow and and if they pay people more is
it based on like their Fame level within
the franchise I would assume but I think
perhaps it's just more like negotiating
kind of thing which obviously
individually like you no one knows whose
contract says what so wow that's so
interesting I love that Sam you got any
questions Sam's like die hard Bachelor I
love Sam yeah she's the best I'm ready
for the my contract is over episode
of questions you know yeah that'll be
really fun I'm looking forward to that
person oh let me ask you a question and
if you can't answer just tell me it's
fine I'll impress you how much like in
Paradise how much sex happens or because
it seems like not a lot right so yeah we
have like the Boom Boom Room which
technically like can kind of happen
whenever
um whoever's into each the other as long
as they both consent that they can
totally go for it but for the most part
there's Fantasy Suites for the final
couples and they individually will
decide but if if a couple goes to the
Boom Boom Room they're gonna cover
they're gonna show it on the show right
because like the last I don't think
anyone did no so last season people were
actually kind of upset because
um it was Marissa and Riley that went to
the Boom Boom Room after their
one-on-one and they aired Marissa
moaning a little bit and people weren't
too happy about that which I agree I
feel like it was pretty unnecessary
um and it's like a night vision shot of
them like rolling around in bed I just
think it's like we can get the idea like
the door closes it has the Do Not
Disturb like we get it but I don't know
they like to take that extra step
um there's a noise issue here
potentially with this uh segment go
ahead Jess no you yeah you keep going
but we have a we have a hair dryer I
have a question
if there are two different couples who
want to go to the Boom Boom Room what's
like clean up like in between do they
like let production know that there
needs to be cleanup no so there's
actually I think if I remember it was
two or three different boom boom rooms
so if let's say hypothetically two
couples want to go at the same night
like they have their own rooms okay good
um and then that place the resort they
have like uh cleaning ladies and all
that stuff they're all like super sweet
too so they take care of everything but
I remember last season I was like crying
and I just wanted to be alone and they
let me sleep in the Boom Room
that would be me but I learned quickly
why it's for couples because they blast
the AC in those rooms and it was
freezing it was so sad
so they changed the sheets though oh of
course yeah thank God are there condoms
and lube and stuff in the Boom Boom Room
yes there are there are okay it's like
these funny little um like packs that
are like sealed and you have to open it
up and yeah oh they have little pockets
love that I remember walking in there I
had brought my stuff in because I was
like so sad that night and I was like
okay at least they're letting me sleep
in here and I just look over at that
table with all this stuff I was like
well I won't be needing that so what
else was in it anything surprising uh no
just that um obviously like you know
good sheets and all that it's just that
the perk of the Boom Room is that
there's AC because everywhere else it's
pretty like open because like like for
example the girls room is called the
tree house um it's like half inside half
outside we have like this whole balcony
but a [ __ ] it's sleeping outside you
pretty much that's pretty wild isn't it
because it's got to be like super humid
yes it is yeah and then in um in
Paradise they have these things let me
look it up it looks insane it's like a
raccoon but they're like these Mexican
ones let me look it up
they are terrifying and they terrorize
us this last season like they rummaged
through someone's bag and you could tell
because they peed all over everything
wow there's crate you guys are fighting
with Critters yes
one thing that stuck out to me during
this season of Bachelor in Paradise it's
not over what dude this season [ __ ]
was like my I think my all-time favorite
Sam did you agree it was so good I mean
it's not over yet but
I love how much they [ __ ] with you
guys oh they did they did I I arrived
I arrived we're gonna throw in me and
four other girls I was like oh they're
gonna hate this like I knew immediately
it was not gonna bowl over well so the
girls didn't like us for like the first
couple days I remember there were some
arguments about the women's bathroom
being dirty
and I was like I was kind of surprised
that they don't have better like service
for you guys to like nope that's the
thing is there's someone who like they
change our sheets and all that and I
know some of the girls I guess is like
like kind of tea but some of the girls
re-shared this video showing the room
like literally freshly made and that was
when only about half of them were there
so of course it was going to look a
little more organized but once you have
like all of the women there it's so many
of us of course there's gonna be some
clutter and are you guys in bunk beds
and stuff we are there's even like a
queen size bunk bed I was sleeping I
slept because it was in the same spot
both seasons too
hmm those are that's a cute animal by
the way
did you look it up I Stan pulled up a
photo of him look at it is that it
they come in and [ __ ] with you they do
are they aggressive no not at all that's
why I was so surprised I'm thinking like
we were asleep and this animal was just
walking around like none of us noticed
so we saw how messed up the bag was and
one day when I was in an interview
outside we could see it creeping through
the trees behind me and we were all just
like frozen it was so funny so cute look
at that thing
uh just another pretty cute you got to
experience Chris Harrison and Jesse
Palmer right true questions about that
talk to us about that yeah so I met
Chris Harrison he was great and then
Jesse Palmer also um just to give a
little background sorry to cut you off
because some people aren't Bachelor now
oh yeah Chris uh what was his name Chris
Harrison was the long-standing host of
bat all Bachelor series I I loved him
um I thought he was great but like two
years ago he got
totally acts from the franchise after he
said some he defended like uh he was
doing Parabellum yeah he was doing an
interview with Rachel who was the first
yeah who was the first black
bachelorette and there was controversy
online about like one of the winners
um going to an antebellum party and he
was like defending it profusely and then
that he said something like
uh weren't you what we all doing stuff
like that when we were kids I don't know
it wasn't good but then anyway long
story short he was like the super
long-running one and he got the
annihilated from the series after uh
some weird comments about the slave
parties yeah yeah and then um Jesse
stepped in who he was already like
Bachelor family he had been The Bachelor
at some point like years and years ago
um but he joined in I wasn't sure at
first because I was like well you know
obviously we were all
um had our own individual feelings about
Chris Harrison anyway really well well
yeah I mean I mean before all the drama
no no no no
obviously we kind of had to like
reconsider something but yeah um
especially as like I mean there's not
many POC on the cast so of course we
kind of have to um take that into
consideration and when it comes to the
kind of comments that you know were
released it's like a little difficult to
navigate but for the most part when I
met Jesse I mean I ended up really
liking him he's honestly really solid um
I was hoping though that the season they
would keep doing the celebrity guest
house but they didn't go with that I
thought that David Spade host was he was
super funny I was hoping they would do
it again I loved David space yeah and I
like that it was every week someone
different but David Spade I could see
him doing it all the time because
Paradise is so not serious yeah totally
exactly that's why I thought it worked
great but honestly
um what's the new guy's name Jesse
Palmer I like him no I like him I don't
even miss Chris
Chris who Jessie's great he's he's like
so cool I remember when we first walked
in me and the girls before we were ever
even on camera or going down to the
beach to interrupt their day pretty much
um we ran into him like practicing his
line like just staring at a tree
practicing his line I thought it was so
endearing I was like he takes it serious
like he really enjoys the job
I love I'm such a bachelor
I'm Bachelor Nation dude the first
season I ever watched was um
yeah oh my God you should go back and
watch some of the other ones if you
haven't I have gone back and watched a
few there's so many seasons dude yes but
um the Colton was amazing so he was The
Bachelor you guys might have heard about
this he's he was closeted gay the whole
time
and he yeah and there was even billion
Billy I he was the Virgin Bachelor oh
yeah he was a virgin but that was like
his whole stick that he was the Virgin
Bachelor but then you find out a few
years later he comes out as gay
like Fouseytube uh what would fousey say
to an older guy right oh my God he said
I felt worthless
yeah I felt ugly yeah I felt gay well
that's I felt that no like that was
based on what they told me sorry
Fouseytube is inappropriate it tastes
like beef jerky
um and I by the way I was so investing
with Colton I watched it's so weird he
went the girl he ended up picking got
ended up getting like a restraining
order and apparently he was stalking her
and being super crazy something about
him like going to her place without her
permission a few times yeah didn't he
put a tracker on her car yes he did that
she got a restraining order yeah that'll
get you restrained for sure for sure
it's just so interesting though that he
was like closeted and then also
I think what he said he made this
Netflix show afterwards where it was
like coming out with Colton or I don't
remember the name I was so invested in
that show dude I was shedding tears and
[ __ ]
but um shedding tears I love emotional
oh yeah because he's came out to his mom
and dad and [ __ ] and they're like super
traditional I like the show I feel like
I'm sure enough friends they kind of his
church friends kind of [ __ ] him right
I think so that's my word but like like
honestly I'm not mad about it at all
obviously because I don't care about
anyone's sexuality but I like I love it
for bachelor Nation because they're
mostly traditional people yeah oh yeah
might get some representation in there
oh he's like a football player too which
I guess that's the thing with like gay
men in the NFL where it's like super
taboo and he was an NFL player so
there's all kinds of interesting angles
with him being gay uh with implications
in his life by the way this is his
fiancee he's a he loves the daddies bro
this man was closeted his whole life and
he came out with like super specific
taste yeah
isn't that interesting
I loved it because I remember in the um
in the documentary he was already
telling people he was in the older guys
how interesting is that
old man
[Laughter]
and this guy looks like quite a bit
older like how old is his fiancee
yeah I'm good by the way just a hair
update I'm getting a little scared
because it's looking pretty it's already
looking straight uh Jess do you want to
explain uh your Technique what are you
doing here
um I like blow dried it first just to
get some of the like you know
curl out and now we're just ironing it
and then I'm gonna like gel it up so
this is a flat iron is that what you
call it yeah and this is the tool the
preferred tool to get curly hair
straight yep yeah it had the appearance
of a thick matte of hair
[Laughter]
all right it's actually looking
kind of quite good I have good
so and there's not even gel in it and
it's already standing straight up
Colton is 30 and his fiance is 38. yeah
it doesn't 30. I was surprised by that
just look old as hell well he's younger
than you dude he's younger than you
first of all wait that's and what makes
one year more than me why does he look
so old
doesn't he look old as [ __ ]
am I crazy no he does look old that Dude
Looks 50. I think I think he's also
wearing he's also wearing Shades which
might be under those I'm gonna find
another photo
[Music]
yeah 38's not that different they're
really cute honestly
yeah we I mean we should hey
we love
bro look at this the gay community took
a [ __ ] massive dub when he came over
Am I Wrong look at these photos dude
he's straight up yes yes yes Colton
Ben likes it
that's so interesting yeah so that's
that so that was my first season that
was a really good one
and the other really good one was uh
what was her name she's like
what's her name
she got kind of that like pageant beauty
pageant and Hannah Brown yeah
Hannah from bio the hand we know the
Hannah we know
whoa I loved the way Hannah
was The Bachelorette I thought she was a
boss oh totally I actually I that was
one season that I didn't watch watch but
I remember like there was so much Buzz
around it like I had no choice but to
know yeah she was she was just like
powerful I felt like
is she engaged now or she just has like
a a guy she's been with for a while I
think she posted about having a
boyfriend but they've been dating for a
little while now yeah yeah okay
yeah but um I feel like this the
bachelor and bachelorette since that
that time has been kind of slow dude I
don't know just not hitting me the same
it's just a lot of the same things
honestly Bachelor in Paradise I [ __ ]
love yeah because it's all these chaotic
personalities coming together on a beach
so yeah people are saying Colton's a bad
dude I don't know yeah maybe I don't
know well yeah I do want to prep you
know I'm not trying to get canceled
either but I'm not super familiar
despite like you know everything I think
that doesn't excuse like yeah his coming
out story can be inspiring but that's
not to excuses past behavior
um but I just see it as perhaps you know
I can only assume he was going through a
really rough patch at that time and
probably
um his actions essentially were a
reflection of that I enjoyed the uh Pete
the pilot season
when I was watching I stopped watching
during that season the pilots are
[ __ ] snooze more like Pete crashing
his plane into the side of the mountain
because he fell asleep at the wheel oh
my God
the first season I sat and watched
through really because it was during
like what the pandemic like there was
nothing really else to watch so I just I
did watch the whole season again
he's a little [ __ ] boring
he's back with uh Kelly
did you see that
was that one of the girls I don't
remember names like YouTube Kelly
Flanagan
should we pull up some uh some videos as
Jess uh
rounds out my double Mo sure are you
still feeling confident back there Jess
full straight
mohawk oh you know what we should talk
about I want to see one bent air
what Dan look at what I got highlighted
you really want to talk about this
oh Dan you gotta eat a chip bro yo you
gotta eat the [ __ ] chip I promise he
said on Monday I'll eat this I know and
I'm gonna break everybody was there hold
on I know and I'm breaking the promise
before you say anything everybody was
there Dan said Monday I'm eating the
chip I did say that and here's the trip
right here I could pop it in my mouth in
10 seconds if I wanted to but I won't
why
because I totally forgot my girlfriend
is uh coming back from being away for a
month a month today she just landed back
in L.A I haven't seen her in a month and
I'm not gonna spend the first night back
with her on the toilet what's that got
to do with eating a spicy chip you know
you know exactly what it's got to do
with it I got home I was fine well I
feel like there's always not taking that
risk you just gotta eat it
maybe there'll always be something but
today is today's not that day that's how
we find out the fiance by the way who
I guess yeah he did yeah he he doesn't
look that old actually in the face you
guys know what Perez Hilton looks like
he kind of looks like him he looks like
who right Perez Hilton
oh yeah you're right I see it yeah
true who knew Colton was engaged to uh
Perez
um
people are saying that's a lame excuse
Dan
okay
so you're gonna do it on Wednesday
uh yeah yeah
you want to check what are we on there
yeah I mean actually now maybe I should
put it on your calendar don't make any
plans for Wednesday let's see uh
Wednesday
yeah today is Wednesday there's nothing
really going on on Wednesday so sure
we'll do it on Wednesday
all right and can we have some kind of
form of punishment if you back out again
reclining in the Scorpion chair
that'd be nice shame that's not
punishment what I thought it was all
crazy like upside down practically yeah
that's more comfortable than this it's
uncomfortable when it's like upright
like I have to do it most of the time
okay that's not good though yeah
we don't like that
every day you donate it you have to eat
another tenth of a spicy chip it's like
interest accruing interest yeah
uh Wednesday should be fine okay I mean
today would have been fine I just it
totally slipped my mind that Ali was
coming back today
I don't want to do that people are
calling you a scammer I'm just saying
scammed that's right you got scammed
what do you want to talk about then guys
got scammed well it was what you wanted
to talk about you were freaking out
about uh this AV story over the weekend
okay okay well no I wasn't freaking out
well you thought it was hilarious I did
the sub show me the the Reddit post yeah
it's right here
um
that looks really good
so by the way this show can you can you
send me the link so I can uh it's in the
doc it's in the dock it's right here
just about it for me oh thank you number
six just say that number six thank you
um here this popped up on the subreddit
and it was so funny uh it says why am I
getting sponsored for you post on
Instagram I had a little different bit
of a experience looking at this okay
well yeah I'll offer you a moment but
here it's it's the and what's so funny
it's you and a and Ian idubbbz at the
boxing match and it looks like so
[ __ ] funny that you would promote
this bro like look at me I hang out with
idubbbs y'all should be following me on
Instagram
I wonder if Ian saw it did he I'm sure
he has he'll probably see it now
so awesome
most of the comments were were actually
funny he's trying to spread fomo
uh
and then um he well absolutely
Goblin which is you know
First Look if you're trying to get away
from that maybe this is not this is
gonna seal the deal forever
but moving on
I was expecting a I'm expecting Amy to
talk about this allegation next time
Ethan runs to the bathroom any thoughts
on that comment no
a lot of people shared that opinion
[ __ ] you have nothing this one was
funny I just have a son urge to buy
Donkey Kong Jungle Beat for GameCube not
a criticism
Amy's never gonna beat the clout Goblin
allegations now
imma skip this one
so uh but anyway that is just so funny
and you were being like yo this post is
so annoying
it's not fair I ain't safe it's not fair
I know I mean you were like dude it's so
annoying that yeah Goblin and I'm like
bro
you gotta admit it's fine no if you yeah
if someone just yeah no it is funny but
I was just posted in Flocka
wait what is Flocka is that an AB
subreddit is there an AV sub yeah I have
nothing to do with it oh my God wait
AB did you know about this yeah recently
I found out about it I can show you the
flock
[Music]
careful this is not moderated yeah
there's a few of these Luca put
yes Flocka wait there's other subreddits
for other crew members there was one for
me a long time ago I don't even remember
what it was
and I think there I think there's an e
in the intern one and uh I mean they're
all there's like 10 people there you
know what I mean but this is good I mean
this is right on we've seen this but
okay okay there's 500 people here
about to be a lot more about to be a lot
more all right so Amy what do you want
to say
in defense of this yeah I know if you
just want to say it's funny wherever but
some people are going way too far as
usual let me first just say that
Instagram gave me an ad credit and
people on the crew have got it as well
let me just say that and not that
they've used it hold on what I'm talking
about what did you say what Olivia
I don't I mean I don't she doesn't even
know what you're talking about yeah
I know what he's talking about don't
defend him I know what he's talking
about okay thank you so what is an ad
credit they give you about 50 well they
gave me 50 I don't know how much they
gave everyone else but they give you an
incentive to advertise and when they do
more than other people oh I don't know
Cameron how much it's true I've gotten
these also thank you yeah wait so how do
you find out about them they it's
automatically shown on your home page
you don't have to scroll where's my
[ __ ] ad yeah what the heck I'm gonna
promote a picture of me and Ian
anyways also I'm gonna post a picture of
me and post Malone
I didn't think it would show like this
like some cav-cav [ __ ] or obviously I
would have never done this but it said
uh to increase profile views and it
automatically shows you it's like you're
recently highest leading uh engaged post
or something like that it gives you a
little thing right there then it asks
you what do you want do you want likes
do you want this and I said profile and
I don't know why it looks like this
ridiculous [ __ ] right here which it
would have been a lot funnier if it was
just me but the fact that it's me and
Ian is really embarrassing because that
was a very meaningful night to me and
Ian's the man and now it just made it
seem like uh I'm using him dude the
Optics is so [ __ ] funny you like
you've got to admit this is just so
hilarious I'm okay listen I know we're
on a comedic podcast it's funny laugh
about us sometimes people the comments
just go what were the comments I didn't
see many or maybe if you go like I can't
wait for him to [ __ ] leave he's just
using A3 to gain out and I want to
clarify two things about the whole Cloud
Goblin meme okay just so you guys know
because I know a lot of you don't I was
live streaming on YouTube and that's
when I first interacted with Ethan Ethan
entered my YouTube live stream and we
started talking then we follow each
other on Twitter okay and also when I
was hired when I first spoke to Ethan
and Neil on the phone I had one question
when I got hired and I said can I still
have my own channel to which they said
of course it's not something it's
something that I've done for years it's
not something that I've I've now that I
work here I'm trying to push it or
something anymore
yo subscribe to Star kill everybody yes
I'll be I'll be your Cloud Goblin thank
you buddy
wait I got an idea this picture is so
funny I know this picture and I never
make like tough guys either we were like
both just [ __ ] around but it's mostly
Ian and then it's like I got an idea for
promoting I'm his little [ __ ]
what Ken
I was saying the other day that I should
post a picture with Ethan now and
promote it before we talk about it on
the show that'd be great but I'm already
promoting a picture me and you on my
Instagram
me with the celebrity
a b
you had a VIP seat to them and I think
ball boxing match with idubbbz yeah no I
had no idea until this post was on my
feet and then I saw oh my God AV he's a
star
so he's worth it so it's working it's
working it's working then and I said to
myself is that a b sitting with items in
the VIP section of the Jake Paul fight
listen in all seriousness I got
emotional at that fight for a second
because it was it was really felt like a
Make-a-Wish kit or something sitting
there like I was very generous of Ian to
invite me but like you know just being a
fan of all these guys for years to be
sitting there it was really cool and I
feel like looking back it was a good
memory and now this post ruined it no it
didn't matter I think that's so cute
yeah we didn't plan that someone said we
looked like uh sweaty waiters yeah
that's you
by the way uh AV just to be real for a
second I
um yeah idubbbz is awesome I'm glad you
guys went and had fun that was really
cool but I don't think I don't think
this ruins the moment it's just a funny
silly thing that we can talk about but
nobody's yeah I don't think anyone's
seriously gonna like Yeah and I don't
know it's annoying I it's like every
time I post something oh Cloud Goblin
yeah like what the [ __ ] do you think I
do what do you what do you think I do
for a living like you know what I mean
like it's it's a little bit annoying but
I understand but this was like no this
is funny no that's what I'm saying that
a lot of the top comments were [ __ ]
hilarious but like nobody else is having
sponsored posts on my feed trying to I'm
trying to look for this free credit in
my account right now
I'm not seeing anything maybe I got I
got some criticism if I may say why why
is this oh the shirt's too it's too
uptight it's got to be on button for one
you button too high it's too high
you want to be Mr Hollywood here but no
Ian see Ian is buttoned down yeah it
looks good he's showing off the tat yeah
you could dude you got that just
unbutton it one you have it you don't
have a chest tattoo do you no not yet we
gotta get one and then unbutton oh
you're gonna get a chest down I'm gonna
get the same one Ian
no but you know what I did that was so
embarrassing there like I already like
not this photo not this photo no while I
was there there's a precursor for this
I'm sitting there trying to play it cool
I feel like the least significant person
there of course Ian and East are really
cool down to earth so they I made me
feel comfortable but I'm sitting there
and I go to ask for water from the bar
and they give me this big ass like
Burger King like water cup and I put it
down for a sec and then Mike and Jeff
walked up and I was saying hi to Mike
and Jeff and I walked back and
immediately it was spilled everywhere
and I was and like it was all the guy in
front of me was like like a UFC champion
of the world I I don't know his name but
um there was like water all over his
shoes yeah bro and like I was just
sitting there and wait how did knock
over I don't know I must have hit it
maybe walking back and like the whole
row is talking about I'm just looking
forward pretending I don't see it
Ian's like oh is that yours I'm like I
know what you're talking about and I
just kept looking forward then they
clear out the whole section of vip's
next time there's like Dan Bilzerian and
like a few other guys all had to stand
up and then a janitor just came up with
the with the mop right up to my shoes
and I'm just depending it's not me
so you got it all over here you got her
over his fit I I got it on a few
people's fifths whoa that is that's
pretty bad bro yeah I don't think I ever
told any it was me but it was me and you
tried to ignore it that's the best part
I don't think I could have like handled
it in the Moment Like consciously I
would have had a panic attack so
try to move on knock it over my wife
yeah don't worry about I listen if
people are saying [ __ ] like that I don't
know who those [ __ ] people are they
ain't fans of this show they just little
hater ass [ __ ]
I we enjoy it for the for the comedy
okay no serious uh hate please that
that's ridiculous
it's funny thank you
but this photo is forever bro sponsored
bro Ayub just texting me he goes man
that's weird as [ __ ] what the hell wait
no I'm kidding oh okay well I can text
him now oh I got banned I'm Tick Tock I
can text Ian now and ask if he saw it
should I do that
if you want sure it'd be kind of fun
kind of funny yeah
let's see I got
[Music]
um
it just ended it didn't get suspended it
just ended
it's interesting right now let me text
oh [ __ ] Phil texted me
says I love you Elon
I'm gonna get him a shirt that says
biggest Elon SIM for his birthday
[Music]
um
okay let me text Ian
um maybe I can call him
might be fun if you call him I gotta
warn him before yeah see if he's
available yeah
Ian Slater one sub
forgive the gift
I said yo can you talk we're live I got
something urgent to ask you
about a b Ian I wish you the best
yeah that's so funny though but I get it
I understand why it bothers you it's
just
it's like the whole universe collided to
make this perfect clout Goblin moment
yeah no it was uh it was it was it was a
rare one
but yet fun yeah it was really fun it
was a really cool experience
that's awesome that's really cool you
got to go there what'd you think were
you impressed by Jake seeing him up
close like that yeah no I've always sort
of wondered like I don't know because
there's always the people online saying
it's not real I've always thought it was
real but I don't know singing in person
you can't deny it I mean he he knows
what he's doing not really I still want
to [ __ ] watch him box a real fighter
like dude come on man
like he's literally just fighting 50
year old retired athletes it's annoying
like and I know the guy he fought this
time what's his name Sylvia or whatever
yeah Salvia Sylvia
it's like he's a big deal in the UFC but
he's [ __ ] 50 years old my Jesus
Christ man
and like Jake is in his physical prime
or something right I mean
I'm sorry it's just I don't care how
great he was he's 50.
yeah I don't know why he just doesn't
find someone his age so that uh he could
prove everyone wrong if that's what
people keep saying
I mean it's smart from like a marketing
though because he gets these big ass
names and it just probably sells so many
tickets dude that's what it's really
about
and actually it's kind of cool for them
because the last guy who he knocked out
uh what was his name again the UFC guy
you got like The Knockout of the year on
him
was it the Nate something or other guy
it's the guy who he had like a world he
knocked him like cold then oh not been
asking um
because his name Woodley yeah Woodley
is that
when he was a UFC fighter
he made more money in this one fight
against Jake Paul than his whole UFC
career he got like two million dollars
for the fight or something damn so I
mean good for him right sure awesome
oh man oh man
um but there it is Abe we we we forgive
you okay 23 000 likes though oh my
goodness was that did the Boost so I
sent the analytics under that
um it's in the doctor okay good and just
so you guys know
the Boost did not help whatsoever so
this was all 50 bucks this is all just
for this moment 50 bucks you spent 50
bucks and it didn't help at all I didn't
spend anything it was the credit it was
the credit well theoretically I don't
know I I ended it as soon as I seen the
post because I didn't yeah you didn't
let it run its course yeah so I don't
know how much
and 50 and so I asked uh Amy to send to
Analytics
so let's see here that seems like good
engagement
right
um
yeah
see we reached
86 000
I think if you scroll down to the
followers versus non-followers it tells
you all you need to need to see yeah but
like that makes sense because you have a
certain amount of followers and they
don't show everyone your [ __ ]
so when you boost it just
but okay
um it doesn't look that impressive yeah
in terms of how it helped yeah
oh also Kim's also maybe another oh yeah
yeah this this is called Titans I forgot
this is weaved together so also avie's
getting caught out on the subreddit for
liking game Star Plus which is also very
funny what happened here
I don't know I must have accidentally
liked it
I don't know what to say he just thought
his beard looked immaculate yeah I mean
like even like my initial thought if I
was seeing this I feel like you'd be
like oh avie's trolling you know he's
trolling the guy that they talk about 24
7 and everyone's like I [ __ ] knew it
right we don't talk about them his
bandana was laid super well that day
right
uh we don't talk right I know we don't
talk yeah you know what I mean enemy of
the I know what you're saying
dude that man that covers so much Dome
with the bandana like he's clearly
have you ever seen someone cover that
much Dome with the bandana
like it's just it's way too deep like
and there's and you can wait look at his
ear look how far down it is right he's
hiding his eyes you're only seeing the
lobe like only the bottom of his earlobe
is sticking out
I get it though like I have the same
thing cover as much as your face as
possible to be more attractive when you
look like me you know what I mean
it's true the ratio of the amount of
face that you're seeing on keemstar
photography world world record low
all right well well uh there there it is
AB is uh
av's journey of from clout Goblin to
rags to Rich just Goblin yep yep I won
Luke goblins by the way last week the
other week just yeah so I am the
official loot Goblin of uh you guys want
to watch Jordan Peterson crying about
Elliott page
again this is a new one
yeah this is a new one but real quick
guys read a comment real quick what go
ahead on that post of keemstar what the
[ __ ] AB traitor why is he even following
Keem and Lake in his posts that's it
that's it
that's my faves how do you think we get
all the juice people
a b
is the is the Mastermind thank you
that happens to me I like posts that are
like
whole if you're like stalking someone or
you know what I mean and then you
accidentally like their [ __ ] and you're
like oh [ __ ] bro oh I [ __ ] up bad
but imagine doing that and not even
noticing which is what happened in Amy's
case
I'm like all his [ __ ] now so anyway
here's Jordan Peterson crying about
Elliot page this man really needs a new
routine
yeah like he's been taking the show on
the road for way too long we need some
new material from Jordan dude
Twitter's a [ __ ] Rat Hole the mob
so here's Jordan crying over uh Elliot
page
so mean to Ellen Page and I think well
you know Ellen Page is a star and she
advertised her transformation and made
the claim that this has revolutionized
her life and then she displayed her new
body in a public forum and got
1.7 million Instagram out there
social media dude details about his life
I don't get 1.7 million likes I've been
Shadow banned
I get my algorithms crushed
dude he's so [ __ ] angry that that
Elliot's clouded up and he's not
well tell me while you were so mean to
Ellen Page and I think well you know by
the way he's still being a dick like a
total [ __ ] douche by dead naming
of course like there's no need for that
it's just rude it's just like super rude
like you're trying to make a point
God he's so pathetic he's such a loser
Oh Ellen Page is a star you know it's a
rat hole his grandma's pubes
let's go he literally said it in his
dream play attack I dreamed I saw my
maternal grandmother sitting by the bank
of a swimming pool
keep going play the whole thing
her genital region was exposed dimly
keep going
hold on one sec
you gotta pull it you gotta pull the
whole thing I have it hold on yeah
sometimes you just gotta pull it here we
go here we go and I saw my maternal
grandmother sitting by the bank of a
swimming pool which was also a river
her genital region was exposed dimly it
had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair
she was stroking herself absent-mindedly
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted into something
resembling a large artist's paintbrush
she pushed this at my face
I raised my arm several times to deflect
her hand
finally I'm willing to hurt her or
interfere with her any further I let her
have her way yeah and by the way it
stroked my face with the brush gently
and said like a child it's a dream that
he's detailing it just in case people
think that's a deep fake or that is
actually an excerpt from his that's from
his book yeah so I'm saying the only Rat
Hole here is your grandma's pubes buddy
I got one about him throwing a kid sure
I'd love to hear it I remember taking my
daughter to the playground once when she
was about two a particularly provocative
little monster of about the same age was
standing above her
brother you're talking about it yes like
holy [ __ ] are you talking about a
two-year-old child a [ __ ] provocative
little much demon
he hit the violence on that monster holy
[ __ ] bro
this little [ __ ] sinner deserves to
go to hell
all right go ahead I watched him move
towards her our eyes locked he slowly
and deliberately stepped on her hands
with increasing force over and over as
he stared me down
as someone who with a three-year-old no
two-year-olds doing that period like
staring him down being like this I'm
looking at you [ __ ]
like this is a two-year-old man they
like literally just learned to walk do
you understand how young that is this
two-year-old deserves to be tried as an
adult he stepped on my daughter's hand
and so I kicked the [ __ ] out of him and
I punched him in the stomach the air
came out of his lungs and I Spit on His
Face
go ahead he knew exactly what he was
doing
up yours Daddy-o that was his philosophy
he'd already concluded that adults were
contemptible and that he could safely
defy them
too bad then that he was destined to
become one
that was the Hopeless future his parents
had saddled him with to his great and
salutary shock I picked and bodily off
the playground structure and threw him
30 feet down the field
30 feet
wait hold on I'm trying to find okay I'm
trying to find a picture of a
dumbass child
okay Chuck did that this is a
two-year-old
we're a monster great and salientary
shops
we
wrapped in Mortal Kombat
I choked him out body slammed them
this is a two-year-old you guys
I think he just committed like a really
serious crime hopeless future his
parents saddled him with
to his great and salutary shock I picked
and bodily off the playground structure
and threw him 30 feet down the field
so do you not have the rest of this do
you know
okay I had told Zach to pull this a long
time ago because I was familiar this is
another excerpt from the same book as
the uh grandma's thing it's the book no
it's the 12 rules for life what yeah
both of those quotes are from 12 rules
for life I think they're from maps of
meaning
the kid one is for sure from 12 years
maybe the grandma one is from his other
book but the tossing the kid and um yeah
that didn't happen right I told Zach to
cut it there but like shortly after he's
like I didn't actually do that but I
imagined it in great detail I fantasized
about beating the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
this two-year-old that is the kingdom to
death that is the thrust of the excerpt
not as him sitting at a park with his
daughter fantasizing about [ __ ] up
two years and again I just need to
emphasize to you guys who don't have
spent a lot of time around young kids
this is what a two-year-old looks like
thank you
let's just want to throw them 30 feet
down the field an innocent harmless
beautiful creature like you know what I
mean this is not there's a bit of Hitler
in everyone
I saw a little bit of Hitler and the
two-year-old it made me want to throw
him 30 feet
all right let's dude and Jordan's so
good he's so easy man he's like come
join us and together we'll end women
[Laughter]
yeah okay let's uh let's go doctor let's
cry more about about Elliot page while
you were so mean to Ellen Page and I
think well you know Ellen Page wait does
this have badass music in the back yeah
yeah whoa
[Music]
wait is this like a manosphere viral
tick tock
well it's from a page called overflowing
wisdom
no this is uh this is a YouTube short
the only thing over following is my
grandma's pubes on YouTube I grabbed
them in my hand like a paintbrush
[Music]
are you looking for yeah I want to read
the comments on this
uh here it is overflowing wisdom here's
the channel
it's like all Jordan Peterson's stuff
that's so awesome
[ __ ] has 300 000 well hey drivers I'll
tell you how to find it just go to
shorts or videos go to shorts and just
sort by most viewed it's probably going
to be one of his topics I got it it's it
gets in there I got it
do you have your passports
did you get your shot I got it Dan
swordfly popular I just want to see
what's up wait oh I got it right there
do you have your passports did you get
your shots girls
[Music]
to America that's what there's a rat
hole hi America
[Music]
to America
[Music]
you're beautiful
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
do you want to come back with me to
prison for a conjugal visit
that's all he gets now man
yeah
will it be you
oh will it be good
[Applause]
[Music]
this is another recruiting concert we
did that
[Music]
and you can come home with me shoes
[Music]
dude he's so wild
[Music]
oh my God people are saying Jess is
doing impossible things Jess is a
magician
dude
I just gotta say that what I'm always
amazed by Ian's green screen I don't
think Ethan saw any of that because it
was uh don't worry about it don't worry
about it all right yeah so here we found
the video
uh from overflowing wisdom and by the
way just out of curiosity
I'm gonna go to their YouTube page
and if you go to shorts and sort by
popular it's all
this one is what's up with these people
I gotta watch all these Jordan Peterson
destroys feminist what year is it
Jordan Peterson it's all Jordan Peterson
destroying women look at this what year
is it
that's like that's from 2017.
these might be old well no they're short
no shorts yeah you're right they can't
be that old they just well no you can
find out the page it was post or let's
see it could also be repurposed content
because I've done that before for some
Brands yeah they're just it's repurposed
for sure but it's just funny that um
people are still consuming this [ __ ]
because this video has 500 000 likes so
it's got to have a lot of views but here
it is and I think well you know Ellen
Page is a star and she advertised her
transformation and made the claim that
this has revolutionized her life and
then she displayed her new body in a
public forum and got
1.7 million Instagram likes for it and
probably in
taste for let's say one young girl who's
confused into becoming sterile which is
one too many for me but it could be is
what is he talking about sterile
foreign
did you forget to ask somebody
Jordan Peterson does not approve yeah
yeah did we forget to consult with uh
it's like uh Dr Oz said I think abortion
should be between the man woman and the
locals the local politicians right
thousand and I have my tendency to feel
a hell of a lot more sorry for a set of
confused isolated and lonely pubescent
girls who have no one to love them
enough to I could take care of that his
theory is that women only becomes trans
when they're pathetic and lonely and
nobody there to love them
sorry that's so crazy dude and he starts
crying who they are then I do for one
over privileged and unfortunately
confused narcissistic Hollywood star
people tell me okay so let's go to the
comments and see
what's the result of this
he gets me every time he can't hold back
tears I guess you get to a lot
yeah
I love how Jordan gets emotional when it
comes to something he really cares about
like hating trans people
I'm very passionate
just admire the passion every time he
gets choked up and is able to swallow
his emotions always make me feel like at
least one person will care
daddy Jordan cares
foreign
you're looking for sane comments exactly
he loves the people the one who are
downtrodden and taken advantage of
he has so much love and compassion for
them
and is insanely angry at the people in
charge who push it
I love that trans people have absolutely
no agency none
it's a conspiracy
perhaps a Jewish conspiracy I was going
to say
the Jews
the Jews
thank you to Derek runts
you says check out Starkiller young fika
Dan Ian family and cam Olivia and Zach
Lewis live at the Troubadour let's go
baby 16. yeah I Gotta Give a special
shot with Derek runs he's he's a Saudi
Prince as well we love him Derek runts
hey excuse me
I will always love how JP can become
overwhelmed by emotions in the middle of
a presentation and still deliver so much
impact guys he's unstable
you can't get get through a paragraph
without crying yeah I love that about
him that's just overflowing wisdom dude
it's just yeah it's overflowing out of
his tear ducts yeah
that's the pressure relief
too much wisdom it sounds like Jordan's
the real victim of uh of uh gender
reassignment he's the real victim and
and it thank God he there's somebody
like him out there looking out for the
downtrodden the underprivileged
the uh rejects rejects of society
you're just confused
because nobody loves you you're alone
and a loser
baby's sad if nobody was looking out for
the 16 to 25 year old white guys playing
Call of Duty who would be looking out
for them well here's the most popular
one so I'm actually curious what's up
with these people Jordan Pearson 12
million views
this one the trans one had seven million
by the way aren't the Chinese
threatening Taiwan at the moment what
are we gonna do without chips I don't
know what these people what are we gonna
do without chips
potato chips oh I gotta pull that that's
gonna come in handy man have you ever
had have you ever had salt and vinegar
chips well we kiss them goodbye bucko
it's nothing but plain Lays from now on
if the woke moralists get their way have
you heard tasted chips made of in
America they're god-awful
they all made a corn Sun Chips make me
sick gonna be eating nothing but Fritos
bucko with no bean dip you ever had
Fritos chili cheese flavor it's an
Abomination kiss barbecue goodbye
dude he's such a [ __ ] idiot
aren't the Chinese threatening Taiwan at
the moment I know where this is going
he's defending Russia he's about to
defend Russia
it's got to be what are we gonna do
without chips I don't know what these
people are thinking what are the uh
environmentalist thinking we love the
planet it's like do you we love the poor
do you okay let's pit the planet against
the poor who wins the planet oh wait
what
I don't think that's a war that needs to
happen
why are we paying a planet against the
floor what does that mean Jordan okay
you like four people well prove it
because I'm put pitting the pennant
planet
we have Goku just toss the whole [ __ ]
planet at a stadium full of
environmentalists who wins now if you
like poor people so much then why why
are they poor
give him your money
okay you don't love the poor that much
how do you prove that how did you prove
that
or do you hate capitalism let's pit
those two things against each other oh
well it turns out we actually hate
capitalism how can we tell
because you're willing to break it and
you know what's going to happen so
what's going to happen in Sri Lanka with
these 20 million people who now have
nothing to eat bro he is fine are they
going to eat all the animals are they
going to burn all the firewood they're
stockpiling fire bro I don't think
anyone is telling the starving people
what I don't think anyone's telling them
they need to be more environmental
friendly
I think that's a luxury I think we'd all
agree of developed countries
he's living in a fantasy world bro he's
setting up like the craziest straw man
arguments look smart
Are you seriously telling the people of
Sri Lanka to grow trees they're starving
they'd eat the chips if they could
we need to send more Sun Chips to Sri
Lanka
are we Germany
it's like so is your environmental
globalist Utopia gonna kill the poor and
destroy the planet and that's okay
because we'll wipe out capitalism it's
like aren't the Chinese what the [ __ ]
did he just say wow straight up word
overflowing wisdom coming out of this
man it's just every poor every it's
coming out of his dick it's coming out
of his ears can you tell me why it has
12 million views like why do people it's
the music bro I swear to God he could
have said anything and they just slapped
them
random 20. yeah you're right love that
Muse that's uh music dude that's our
most liked video on Tick Tock that's
like nine million views
that uses that music you watched like a
Andrew Tate thing and I made it
oh yeah yeah we do more please yeah
okay I'll get on it did you just make a
video of Ethan just like rambling
incoherently for like three or four
minutes and then just have it over that
music I'll do it now okay and I'll try
to be like super serious about it all
right yeah I'll add the music post okay
perfect actually but it needs I need you
need the vibe yeah do we know what song
that is like it's some royalty-free
thing it's Gotta Be I don't know if it's
no not that one
it's got to be the one
this one goes what what do we do without
if you just chips Brits panic
if you search Sigma Rule song on YouTube
it comes up
here
everyone's talking about the chips
comment
here I gotta do
how we looking Jess
[Applause]
let's see
we're gonna have to bust out could you
mind if we bust out a um
a uh leveler or do we have one day yeah
a measure yeah we're gonna have to no no
a leveler the level yeah
damn I gotta say though I didn't think
it was possible that's insane
is it harder than you thought or just
like what you expected yeah you're like
a little curvy but it's like pretty
[ __ ] good
damn
yeah so I mean it's definitely
it's definitely looking pretty clean
Jess
look at that like Moses looks like the
red ski party yo this kind of fire look
at that from the profile
let's go
[Laughter]
Dan is uh got the level the leveling to
allow to make sure
no that's a centered bubble yeah
okay I think we gotta love them all I
think we got a little lower
you know it's crazy damn yeah okay
there it is guys I'm glad we did this we
had to do this at least once before I
cut my hair Jess the magician
thank you guys
uh they she makes miracles happen they
said it could never be done but here it
is
watch it bounce around
[Laughter]
Bella Simon Says shout out to my girls
Paige in Lalane
they are wonderful people they are
little people thank you
thank you that hair with that shirt
rocks all right
yeah but have you got a donation from
eloquine oh no ela's here I love this
look no joke all caps in the chat three
exclamation marks
Ely just gave me ten dollars back to me
actually she started with 10 and then
she gave me seven back right because
YouTube picks are cut laughs
so I appreciate that yo that looks
[ __ ]
crazy dude I can feel it too like I can
feel the air resistance you look fast
like that [ __ ] is not moving I'm gonna
start flapping make you fly up
they don't move
oh it also feels kind of like not that
hard it actually feels nice that's crazy
wow
thank you thank you thank you should we
promo you do you use your Instagram or
something you like uh yeah it's just
Jess period Switzer can you send me the
link so I can open it oh thanks guys
what was the last name Switzer like
Switzerland
oh idubbz got back to me
Ela said Wes the queen wjs
okay I'm calling items or right here
let's wait yeah but let's pull up Jess
is uh yeah I got it
thank you to just the hair goddess
if you loved uh Sam's beautiful red look
and or Ila's uh this Jess is the genius
behind it all why thank you and I could
say that Ela has searched high in love
for a hair person she likes
and she has a
she has happily landed on Jess so there
it is Jess Switzer
thank you so much
what do you think is this a Vibe the
back is crazy though because usually the
back you probably would cut right
or no no
yeah yo I got that stegosaurus swag
the dope ass dinosaur bro
right now they look so fast Dynamic yeah
well going forward I'd imagine yeah yeah
speed speed yeah that's some fast hair
okay
um
I'm gonna call Ian Maybe
okay Dad
and then can you send me uh can you send
on WhatsApp the link to that post so I
can send it to Ian yeah I can just send
it to him I don't have his number no no
no no no let me hear hello
hello hey so we're live just so you know
okay I won't say anything bad no it's
okay I just want you you know I just got
I just got to disclose that how are you
I'm pleasant pleasant okay I like that I
like to hear that
um I wanted to I know you took a b or
invited Amy I don't know if you took him
I don't know what that means but you
invited him to uh Florida for the Jake
Paul fight which was awesome he had a
great time and uh that was cool
yeah did you know by the way that he was
the one that spilled that giant jug of
water
giant jug of water at the bar he spilled
a giant is that our seats I got it from
the bar he got it at the seats there was
like a huge spill of water oh yeah there
was a huge [ __ ] spill they had to
come in with a bunch of mops and
everything and it had to like go through
the aisles before janitor was like
trying and not invade people's personal
space but he had his long-ass mop and
went all the way down AB speed and he's
like he literally hit my feet yeah so he
asked you asked AB if it was him and he
said no at the time but it was him oh
man Butterfingers
that's a mistake yeah
that's that's actually not the reason
I'm calling I'm calling to show you
something that popped up on the
subreddit and I just want to get your
snap judgment on it okay
okay where's the link I need the link
it'd be so much easier for me to send it
baby stop okay don't interfere okay
where do you want me to send it to you
on WhatsApp yes on WhatsApp
this is my thing now I'm doing my thing
all right so I'm sending you a link just
look at it and give me your snap
judgment and then a b can say whatever
he wants to because if he starts talking
now it'll ruin the thing
okay all right I just sent you a Reddit
link
just open it look at it and then
hello
oh a b are you spy are you
are you
paying to have hands around
holy [ __ ] dude every time we hang out
man everything every time I see you
yeah that's funny right I mean it's kind
of wild
I'm kidding yeah
I like it though that's a good pick
okay now now we look like greasy waiters
yeah I agree
yeah so Abe you can explain though
because obviously I don't want to know
yeah ab's explanation I don't know if he
can hear you but he he got a free credit
on Instagram oh yeah and then I've done
the same thing before and he just ran it
and it put that picture you see why he's
the [ __ ] man
and um people were posting it on the
subreddit because he he was funny it's
funny that's it I just wanted to show it
to you that's beautiful yeah no that's
that's good to do back in the day I used
uh Twitter ad credits to promote my
tweets and there was like a lot of
garbage Tweets in it
yeah so Amy do you want to say anything
to Ian uh I think we got the confusion
uh just cleared up there all right
nothing love you buddy don't you think
it's better than not yeah yeah yeah yeah
but let's be honest before you knew that
AB kind of got done Dirty by Instagram
what was your first initial thought
uh but I don't I mean I don't think what
do you mean God's Done Dirty by
Instagram what are you talking about
there it is
what he's he's cool with that he's he's
not he's not oh I wasn't worried about
it yeah I know yeah he's good yeah
anyway that's it
more money
you got you've got Ian's promo that's
funny maybe maybe we should keep it
going live let's put it on everyone's uh
let's Infuse it with like a shitload of
money let's put like 50 Grand
it's not the best possible outcome I
mean I'll put some money up for that
maybe are you cool with that or no yeah
let's do it you're in let's sponsor
every one of my posts
you can be like the Tai Lopez of
Instagram just invading everybody's feed
just standing here with my friend Ian
zero my friend Ian
knowledge that's funny we should do that
okay anyway I just want to check in I
didn't want you to get the wrong idea so
I wanted to clarify it with you uh
before you saw if you saw the post and
we're like man what the [ __ ] maybe but
we cleared it up so that wouldn't happen
yeah yeah the beef is squashed all right
cool good good I don't want you making
like a Content cop about me or something
see you later all right love you buddy
take care be good bye train hard
here in my garage that was uh Ian
of idubbb spin
that one good I think I think that one
good
he's a gracious guy he wasn't gonna he
wasn't gonna get mad at AV for that oh
yeah yeah people don't expect it of Ian
because he's but his uh Persona is kind
of like edgy
uh irreverent
YouTube Community but he's a very nice
guy very sweet sweet guy definitely
I do like the idea of paying
I think that's really funny to just keep
that perpetually promoted so it just
never goes away that's the only one I
wanted that I want to post one with you
today and sponsor it
I love it it's kind of a funny way to
control yourself I'll match you bro I'll
match it but it's got to be something
like
um I can't believe I got a pick with H3
or something I don't know
oh Cam just did it
wait is this sponsored yeah with this
yeah I use my 50 bucks for this you did
yeah
how do I check if I've got 50 yeah
it popped up when I went to promote it
so
yeah I'd always dismissed those without
even looking so I probably missed it so
hold on if I go to profile
yeah there's got to be like a
um
boost yeah it's got to be a boost right
is it the Boost button yeah it's boost
oh
my God I don't see the Boost button
where's my Boost button you have to go
to the photos on your dude I swear to
God I click a photo and there's no oh
these are all videos you've been shadow
man your algorithm's been pressed
algorithms okay boost post let's see
what boosted boost post you don't have
to put a credit card in four anything
for the free 50. oh wow
it was already in for like donations
but I don't yeah donations I know yeah
like if you donate to a charity
sometimes yeah
oh I should I should promote the one of
my ass where I turn around and it's my
bear
holy [ __ ] I'm gonna boost this the way
we should promote Cavanaugh [ __ ]
that's true wait where's a good
Kavanaugh post no I think the ass one's
funner
dude people can get so mad look this
post right here my bare ass I never
figure I might get that will get your
band dude yeah a bad idea I'm not trying
to get banned off another social media
just yet
okay whatever it's something to do
another time
but yeah I'm down what do you oh dude
James or Shane Dawson just put out a
Jeffree Star
yeah a new Jeffree Star series what year
is it
what more is there to say about Jeffree
Star what year it's like I watched the
first one I haven't watched maybe they
dropped dropped second it was
essentially just like I thought it was
going to be an ad but then at the end
they were like no we actually never
released this and we're they're building
not going to I think that's what's good
yeah yeah they want people to beg them
yeah please you guys
what's funny about Shane Dawson and
Jeffree Star clapping is they're the
only two people that will work with each
other yeah
match made in heaven
okay Zach where are we going with that
wasn't me dude oh I was I was opening
the video and I automatically played for
a second uh thank you Sonia vigil for
the gift Jesse are you leaving
thank you so much thank you Jess shout
out oh you did it
I thought it couldn't be done I really
did but I stand before you as a double
Mohawk King
of that thank you so much
[Music]
she's going to send you an invoice right
Sam sent it to you
okay good thank you Jess love that
appreciate you
well it's so nice to be back doing live
shows you know I've missed it
just the old crew back together again
it's only been two and a half hours
you say only
well you know we usually I mean hey we
gotta do three four or five [ __ ]
hours here for at for a genuine app
I barely even got through the dam uh top
of the show
great
Abe are you okay I didn't mean to give
you such a hard time it's just it was so
fun I didn't think you gave me a hard
time at all yeah yeah we love you we
love baby it's okay it builds character
thank you that's right
she's right can we maybe take a picture
together and I post it on my Instagram
[Laughter]
Ethan versus liver King Oh no I got
another Alpha now D it's it's short wait
is it the same song position because no
but it's so big and sometimes fast oh
[ __ ] it got four dude it got 400 000.
what are they doing with the [ __ ]
color timing that made you look [ __ ]
yeah nuts
this is an account a man A A man
among the men A man among men oh A man
among men
A man among the men how are you gonna
milk an oath yes uh the alphas [ __ ]
hate me man it's awesome now do you have
to have sex in a certain position
because you're so big and sometimes fat
guys have up to the problem they have to
they have to go into a certain position
because I mean you're massive right so
what position do you have to go into
position are you guys fully flexible
yeah
here's the thing
um never talk about my wife
[Music]
wait isn't there like a watermark here
for like the free version of like
some editing app
uh maybe dude the bar is so low for this
Alpha content
like what now do you have to I love the
title of it
liver King embarrasses Ethan Klein he'd
cut out like
the best part
and
clearly you were the one embarrassed in
that situation
liver King oh you think I embarrassed
him of course yeah
what are you talking about I was not
embarrassed at all but yeah you were
like basically trolling him oh the
comments are so good rare rare liver
King W okay they don't like liver King
extremely common you think Klein W
I need basically the comments I'm just
looking for the Rarity rating of the L
or W here
mid-range somewhat common
freak somewhat frequent uh liver King w
ow so this this is basically all the
haters right here H3 used to be a peak
YouTuber
and was one of few that genuinely made
me laugh okay
but but bro he has fallen off so much
it's embarrassing shut the [ __ ] up Fogel
that's that's username by the way Fogel
McLovin Fogel McLovin it's it's actually
a compliment because it's basically like
I actually think you're really funny and
talented but now that you attacked my
masculinity disagrees with me then
you've fallen off so it's actually I
really take that as a compliment I mean
I'm glad that
you think I'm funny essentially oh my
god oh I think he he's talking about
liver King but that comment said bro's
not even fat
thanks man yeah he's talking about
Liberty of course
I agree with liver King here oh thanks
for the comment there nutsy920
appreciate you sharing your thoughts on
the situation I agree with Liberty here
why would anyone upvote that agree what
is it what does he agree with yeah
what's the agreement
never talk about liver King's wife in
that context I agree I agree but why
would anyone like this
no dude they just they hate you and
there's people saying negative things
about you so they press like I really
don't think it's that dude people just
go down here and like everything yeah
there's a real man right there that
isn't scared to get into a conflict with
another man yeah hold up
you're talking about dude both of you I
don't it's hard to tell because with the
with the context that we know it's easy
to interpret that as being about Ethan
but I'm pretty sure it's about liver
King he's Swedish you're probably on our
side no perhaps this is kind of a
compliment too why does Ethan think half
the things he says is okay
I'm just edgy and wild like that bro I
just say what's on my mind I'm real and
authentic
[Music]
uh Ethan Defoe would have been thinking
about that answer late at night on his
own if Louver can give me any details
the milk and Oprah if you smelled that
dude you'd understand yeah really that
comment is
the stench is I'm still washing I'm
still Neti potting my nose
so that's fun
people probably think we're exaggerating
it's
impossible it's impossible to convey how
bad that man smelled just imagine what
his nuts smell like bro
like after they have sex and again I'm
sorry to Stew on that but like you know
after sex it can be stinky
yeah
and stuff and it makes sense but when
these two people do don't shower and
exercise all day in Texas heat yep when
they come together and smash genitals
there has got to be of such a foul
[ __ ] odor that emanates from that and
it kills the paint from the [ __ ] wall
probably the background that lives in
their like pubic hair because you know
he he doesn't manscape and neither does
she he laughed at the question yeah the
the bacteria that swap between their
pubic hair and and and and festers right
and and and it's got to be unreal dude
yeah
ferments yeah the cultures they
literally like they're growing down
there you could probably take a swab of
of whatever gigs balls
and cook a piece of bread I was gonna
say you could toss that you could toss
that right on the sourdough it's a good
starter right there
I can milk an oat from that it's a good
starter
[Music]
bottle that
FICA fish eating competition this sounds
really interesting
oh is this what goes on in Sweden
I haven't seen this oh my God
Guinness World Record Zoom strowman
bro I'm I'm having Swedish people
message me all the time like you gotta
teach Ethan how to say this it's
strumming
strumming strumming
that's good yeah when you break it down
it's actually not that hard like when
you look at the words
pretty good yeah
strumming sir strumming yeah that's
better that's good thank you Ethan my
pleasure man I'm here to accommodate
okay let's see what happens uh the world
record uh fika fish
now
I see they took the liquid out but
yeah he's told us over and over again
you're not supposed to do it the way
he's done it no no but that that's raw
fika I'm not taken away from oh I'm sure
it's still horrible but yeah but maybe a
little like juices in there yeah the
juices yeah I mean it's definitely
better
dude that old guy's gotta win right dude
you could probably you could probably
take a funnel like at the back of uh
liver Kings oh he's like the shape of
his back yeah and just collect all of
that can it and you could store this the
storming in there you think so yeah yeah
vinegar sweats vinegar
that old man I knew that old guy would
win this is [ __ ] breakfast for him
yeah
I would think there's people better than
those two yeah you guys would [ __ ]
smash that recording oh wait that is a
lot of food they had there like the
weight that was
well you can see I mean
[Music]
I don't I can't believe this is the
world record I agree
yeah it's fast forwarded so he killed a
whole ball here they both did then
they're going for the second bowl
that's a lot of salt
yeah it is an etiquette or whatever it's
in there dude their bodies are shutting
down
but yeah you would think there's someone
that can just take like infinite amounts
you nice would win that yeah no doubt
you know like inhale that [ __ ] no
question you're gonna get him out here
in Sweden right yeah
but that's like a pound of fish 309 400
grams I've been snoring drainable I
guess that's quite a lot
Drano for Christ's sake I don't wipe my
ass bro
uh what else we got here as we are
winding down you want to read out this
uh 100 Dono real quick 100 Dono think
I'm gonna get it
from oh it's going too fast it's I put
in the president uh Nikki says hi
history family it's my 21st birthday
today family
I've listened to the Pod every day for
the past four years listening eases my
anxiety and helps me sleep just want to
thank you for your hard work hit it Zach
I'm 21. [ __ ] you
yo where'd that come from
Zach just did it oh
I thought Dana is some sort of like a
sexual invitation yeah Dan was trying to
[ __ ] hit it was trying to Alley up
Zach
no no Zach understood the assignment he
played he played the sound bite did he
understand it because he's back there
clapping
well who knows really what she meant uh
yeah I'd have to ask her well that what
right
yes I'm kidding thank God
[ __ ] you
yes it's a joke
but it is hard to tell sometimes so I'm
not going to blame you
uh for for for not for not the kitchen
sometimes it is a joke and sometimes
it's not I did catch on to it though I
want to open uh
Elon
we had this whole post
of taking massive L's here it is that I
wanted to look at was pretty funny
Elon ma let's see Elon Musk money
you get me
what should I say the way it just says
money without like my favorite is yeah
money
[Applause]
I give you
oh Lord I just told Phil he's dead to me
all right Twitter says Twitter needs to
become by far the most accurate source
of information about the world that's
our mission what the [ __ ] are you saying
you idiot loser
uh Kyle Grant Hamstead and to do this
I'll let anyone who gives me money
appear to be as a legitimate source of
news rather than just ensuring all
legitimate sources of news are confirmed
to be who they say they are exactly
oh and then his response was like really
unhinged crazy you represent the problem
journalists who think they are the only
source of legitimate information that's
the big lie hi
you know Steve from uh
Steve from some pool cleaning business
or jet ski dealership in Minnesota is
far more qualified Halloween how are we
as a society gonna pretend like there's
not more
legitimate news sources like come on
dude
you literally tweeted out yes like a
week ago that Nancy Pelosi's husband uh
there's more to this story than right he
tweeted out the stupid
like a conspiracy thing
the world's richest man just banned
cartoonist Jeff uh Jax from Twitter for
making fun of him what was the Jeff
Jack's way I remember it was really
funny
I caught one of them I he was going off
like you and there was a bunch let me um
honey I'm actually familiar with that
uh
uh comic artists so I think it will
probably be on his subreddit Emily said
I came home to my dad watching bench if
you're on full blast I unplugged the
router and he has been cursing trying to
figure out what's been going on for the
past 10 minutes
well you actually just violated his Ben
Shapiro's free speech so you should
apologize
Emily uh just violated my free speech
she unplugged the router
I am inside your walls bin oh uh just a
side note this is the two-year
anniversary today from Rudy giuliani's
press conference out outside the floor
oh that it's a holiday what are we doing
here
it's hard to it's actually
it it's hard to grasp just how insane
[ __ ] was then
content was on tap for sure that was the
funniest [ __ ] that man went outside a
Four Seasons total Landscaping because
he thought it was the fourth season
hotel and still held the press
conference when he realized it was some
back alley across the street from a
dildo shot not many weeks after he
literally melted like brown goo yeah
like gazorg from uh it was so bad
oh my God here it is uh two years ago
today
this is an official Trump
moment
sloppy disgusting filthy [ __ ] animals
gotta be one of the best
things ever I mean wow wow
oh so here it is he said Grimes never
said I have a weird dick and smelled
like nachos and if you repost this you
will be arrested
yo he did like what the [ __ ] and look
he's not even using his profile picture
it's like nobody it's the whatever yeah
nobody would ever [ __ ] think that
this was real this is my point he's
Banning people who are impersonating or
making fun of him this is there's other
accounts that are getting impersonated
that nothing's happening like this is
about him silencing people goofing on
him it just is
and it's his app he can do whatever [ __ ]
he wants but it's embarrassing for him
the remaining staff at Twitter are
actively bullying me now Jed from
accounting called me little baby [ __ ]
boy to my face and nobody even said
anything I mean obviously I fired him
having my goons break his wife's leg but
still it hurts
yes great so he got banned so shout out
shout out also it's like these are
comedians like making jokes you're just
being such a [ __ ] baby dude
Tesla when they see a little kid
crossing the street this was the best
going forward that's so [ __ ] good wow
wow how many likes did this one end up
getting it must have gone super viral
such a good one
damn
uh going forward any tour handlers
engaging impersonation without clearly
specifying parity will be permanently
suspended and this guy responded
if only there were some system of
verification available
to a segment of the user's base most
prone to be impersonated
is it possible you could build something
like that for the platform
uh that got 212k so good so good oh my
God
a respectable lawyer in response to that
same tweet said hi I'm Elon Musk parody
three years after Jeffrey Epstein pled
guilty to procuring a child for
prostitution and shortly after his
release from prison I took my ex-wife
tatula Riley to his house not parody
Mamma Mia
I send a uh the calzone into space
Italian parody
uh what is he talking about though
shortly after Jeffrey Epstein pled
guilty his ex-wife to his house okay
yeah so his ex-wife at one point came
out in an interview I think it was like
a year or two ago defending Elon about
the picture with jeslane the one that
you know people always post or whatever
saying I was there at that party too
neither of us talked to her for any
extended period of time it was a big
party there was lots of people being
introduced or whatever and then
I don't know why she felt compelled to
say this she was like we did go to
Jeffrey Epstein's house one time a few
years after that dude awesome
which is just like oh it's almost like
that's way more interesting than the
just lame picture
so was she trying to snitch
maybe I mean it is his ex-wife
well I'm sorry but this is one of the
best Tweets ever made
this this is just a masterpiece
going forward this just looks so good
has anyone ever successfully ratioed
Elon on Twitter yeah of course I'm sure
it happens every day yeah
sure it happens
um
Aaron Carter died I know much about
Aaron Carter but rest in peace I mean he
was
an addict right I believe so I Sarah uh
Trisha dated him I think for a minute
what yeah yeah she did that yeah I don't
know that dated Aaron Carter I just know
Aaron Carter from being the
was it Nick Carter yeah and he was like
the younger brother of one of the
Backstreet Boys Backstreet Boys he had a
wildlife of like living in the shadow of
his bro and we're trying to make it and
it was very interesting character man
when he was young though he when he was
on his top Prime he I mean he had hits
man yeah he had yeah like I used to when
I was younger I used to listen to that
[ __ ] and I even think I went to an Aaron
Carter concert when I was like five
really yeah that's a good song Aaron's
party we used to listen to that Aaron's
party huh
wait was he the one that had the the
song with Shaq how he beat Shaq dude
yeah okay never mind I am a fan and he
didn't like uh I want candy remake which
that was that's horrible yeah I don't
know how they didn't say how he passed
but apparently
I'm assuming it was drug related but
obviously I don't know because I know he
was having issues with that but I don't
know I'm just assuming but
says he was found dead in a bathtub in
Lancaster still unknown but you know
what drugs is a [ __ ] man those things
will [ __ ] eat your heart and soul in
your whole life so that's but rest in
peace to Aaron Carter
uh who uh of I want candy Fame yeah
no he was I think I think he was like
nine years old
um
because but who knows Candyman well he
didn't write that song No I know but the
cover of a yeah yeah I want candy
just saying he was a Partridge Family
song no it was I think it was um
in the 80s it was Bow Wow Wow that did
it
it's wild that I was just talking to Ian
um my YouTube friend items when we were
at the fight uh about who uh Ian items
the big YouTuber yeah how many Subs does
he have
around seven million is that the guy you
promoted the photo with
yeah yeah
um I was just talking about Aaron Carter
with him because Aaron Carter did a
celebrity boxing match with him and
Lamar Odom and it was I was just seeing
that [ __ ] I've ever seen yeah that was
recently he boxed he got his ass
annihilate I mean obviously he's
fighting and he probably weighs like 110
pounds or something he was doing like
spins around every time he got punched
in that it was wild like a cartoonish
yeah
seeing birds flying around his head and
[ __ ]
my roommate had been watching Aaron
Carter closely for years because he
always goes on like in here he used to
always go live on Instagram live and
when he died she texted me devastated
because she was a big fan yeah you know
it's very shocking it is sad I mean it's
always sad to see it people dying too
young man it's just
rest in peace man
he's a son too a baby son
he was what now he has a baby son oh
that's smart that's horrible that breaks
my heart
[Music]
damn
well anyway Sam did 911 apparently
okay Sam this is a huge story I'm glad
we're getting to this so Sam got posted
wait who's Sam
uh yes Sam who's Sam Temple
Sam Temple of the crew
yeah yeah
so Sam Temple
crew member got blasted on a subreddit
called I Am the main character how about
the worst sub you could ever be on to
clearly you haven't been to H3
production so
yes so um was this a tick tock or yeah
yeah it was a tick tock so here let me
pull up the tick tock first
and then we can respond
uh can you someone pull that up I don't
have a link to it
and I think the music is copyright as
well the music is copyright and the
video is literally just for statically
holding it so the screenshot says when I
was four the day after 9 11 my mom and I
went to TJ Maxx and I stood up in the
shopping cart and sang the national
anthem as loud as I could because I
thought America really needed to hear it
and everyone in the store clapped when I
finished and they gave me a gift card
now when I saw this posted I was like
these people are so stupid like it's
obviously a joke I appreciate everyone
defending me by saying you guys it's
she's from H3 it's a joke this is
absolutely not a joke this 100 happen so
this really blew my mind yeah because
all the comments are like y'all are
stupid she's obviously kidding
um but of all the things that didn't
happen this didn't happen the most
yet here we are this is kind of changing
my whole perception of this subreddit
Sam is saying in fact she even has a
voice message of her mom to corroborate
that this did indeed happen
it's also just uh it's checking all the
boxes for that subreddit because that
that uh every and everybody clapped
that's like the meme on that subreddit
which I didn't know until I was reading
those comments it was like oh I
shouldn't have said everybody I suppose
but but was this meant to be funny or
like what was your intention on posting
this I randomly remembered it and I was
like God that's so [ __ ] cringe I
that
so and then okay well let me open the
voice message of your mom it actually
blows my mind that you're saying this
happened when you said that I said
you're [ __ ] lying no it happened all
right I promise I swear on everything it
happened well here's your mom I said you
got to get a note from your mom to
corroborate this because nobody's gonna
believe you
hey Ethan hey everybody this is Denise
Samantha's mom Samantha asked me to talk
about the TJ Maxx singing episode that
she had yeah
shortly after 9 11 we were out shopping
and Samantha just started singing the
words just belting it out getting louder
and louder and when she was done all
these ladies just came up they were
clapping and cheering and patting around
the back and oh she even got a gift
certificate one of the ladies with
Potter when they brought it back she had
an impressive memory let me tell you she
knew the national anthem and in
kindergarten she could recite all the
presidents in order
now your mom just went on a tangent yeah
dude that's such an incredible Story how
old were you
I was four I was almost five though I
was about to be five and you said they
used to make you sing the national
anthem in school like every day yeah
everyone on that sub was like she was
four there's no way she knew the
national anthem we had to sing it every
day yeah we had to sing the national
anthem every day yo when I think back on
the Pledge of Allegiance that's kind of
freaky and weird that we were pledging
allegiance to the flag
to me I think they still do it I
realized that when I was like 11 or 12 I
remember like it Dawning on me how like
creepy it was like Nazi [ __ ] yeah and
and then I stopped doing it and then
it like caused problems for me like they
were I aren't you yeah like the t-shirts
would like like pull you aside and be
like and like interrogate you like why
you aren't doing it I was just like I
don't know it just seems kind of weird
you know the word here I I think I
remember them all I pledge allegiance to
the flag of the United States of America
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all and that you
would have to put your right hand over
your hand over your heart stand and
rehearse the pledge I always said
growing up uh one nation invisible with
liberty and justice for all if anyone
else he's always mouthing
No I um in Middle School my school took
it a step further and we had to learn
the state song Too in Oklahoma
do you know the state capital song
no I don't think so I'll show you oh I
know
do you want to sing it Yesenia which
state and that was years ago I don't
remember that but I know it was like oh
Oklahoma
come sleeping down the plane it was so
ridiculous oh but that one's more fun
and less like yeah that's a problem
yeah that's from Oklahoma so you're
talking about the Alabama Alaska area
the one where you sing all the states
yeah yeah that one I remember learning I
know the Baton Rouge Louisiana
Indianapolis Indiana what the [ __ ] for
the capitals yeah everything I know
every single state capital just give me
like five minutes and I'll sing
yeah love how do you feel about that
pledge does that freak you out oh it's
like literally psychotic I totally agree
it is it's really I might tell Mike yeah
you don't have to do that yeah we all we
all did it growing up I pledge
allegiance to the flag and I will
[ __ ] die and kill whoever I need when
I grow up I will lay my life down I
don't even know the Swedish Anthem like
the national anthem
uh we know it there it is
I don't know for Sweden meatball
meatballs
that's racist
you're being racist right now
sweetest National Anthem is called
which means thou ancient thou free oh I
like that yeah that's Pride that's good
it's powerful it's powerful it's
beautiful it was originally named song
Till Norden which means song to the
north that's kind of badass uh the north
remembers yeah
[Music]
we have
yeah Pledge of Allegiance is so weird
man yeah no that's kind of crazy but I
don't want to talk too much about that
and then they make you say God there's
literally in our constitution says
separation of church and state and
they're making kids say one nation under
God In God We Trust I remember that was
like a big debate too when we were kids
actually that's probably
now that I'm thinking back I remember
there was like a controversy because
they were trying to take the god back
out and then a bunch of religious people
got very upset about that and there was
like a big culture War thing going on in
like the late 90s I say take the whole
damn thing out and I think that's why
that's what got me to stop doing it
because I think I like talked to my
parents about it my dad was like yeah
this [ __ ] weird you don't have to do
that right
your dad seems cool by the way yeah I
like your dad then how my dad would be
like
[Laughter]
yeah
you better learn it because they'll ask
you they might ask you to recite it of
course I know it already actually I just
do it do it no no no no not right now
by the way Elon Musk shirts available
for a limited time Elon Musk is a giant
piece of [ __ ] loser
in honor of my being banned from Twitter
how do we celebrate with this one-time
restock of Elon Musk is a giant piece of
[ __ ] pre-sale thank you thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Laughter]
um
I pledge allegiance to the flag United
States under God indivisible liberty and
justice for all what a joke
some brainwashing [ __ ] scam I'm
reading like the English translation of
the Swedish one I gotta say this one's
this one's pretty badass national anthem
not like a pledge I guess it's do you
think about God in there
they might do uh
uh no it's mostly just talking about how
badass Sweden is yeah mountains and [ __ ]
right yeah exactly you old you free you
mountainous North you quiet you joyful
Beauty I greet you loveliest land upon
the Earth your sun your Sky your green
Landscapes you are enthroned on memories
of great olden days when honored your
name flew across the earth I know that
you are and remain what you were yes I
want to live I want to die in the north
wow
no but that's that's the that's the
words of their that's the English
translation of the Swedish national
anthem yeah because our Anthem is like
just about like War just about a big
battle Yeah Yeah but yo theirs is so
much better Yep they're like we were in
the trenches [ __ ] dying
fireworks and [ __ ] and it was [ __ ]
horrible but we did it it's like come on
what about the country say something
nice about the country
do you guys learn about all religions in
school or just Christianity yes okay
um I had a whole class about religion
and middle school or high school not my
school I learned about it in a religious
studies in Muslim Islam Hindu Buddhism
Christianity and Judaism well that's
nice yeah my my schools didn't offer
anything like that I wish they did I
wonder if it was an elective class or
something
did did you guys have abstinence only
education no I did not they told us how
to yeah they showed us everything what
no yeah we weren't really taught about
like safe sex they always said the
safest form of sex is to not have it
well they say that but then they also be
like but use a con yeah in California
yeah but you in the South the banana
demonstration and all that it was all
now they'd be like I tell you what man
down here in the south
when I well you must not be having sex
because I tell you what girls ain't no
Barton that baby no more oh come on now
if you don't want to be yourself a child
bride don't be taking no dicks girl
that's all I'll tell that's all I got to
say about that
yeah what did they tell you in absence
only what like how what's the scope of
the class if they're just saying don't
have sex they teach you about like STDs
and like hygiene it's mostly like
hygiene [ __ ] in general that ours was
had that as a component as well but yet
they
didn't do the abstinence only thing here
in California I mean they called it
abstinence only education right so I
remember what they did is like well if
you don't get pregnant don't have sex
but here like if you're gonna have sex
using a condom is 99 effective and then
they would go pulling out is 50
effective I feel like that's
misinformation it's got to be better
than that but they made it they made it
I mean I think we all know empirically
that it's yeah no no I agree I think
it's probably but they made it sound
like if you have sex with well they're
assuming that you don't have strong pull
out game
I thought they're like 50 of the time
she gonna get pregnant you have sex I
was like whoa that's crazy yeah I know
something embarrassing I believe that
[ __ ] until like a couple years ago to
leave what which word that if you don't
use a condom then it's pretty much like
instantly somebody's gonna get pregnant
yeah I mean it I did too it's kind of
you learned it is kind of presented you
kind of just learn it when you're
actually trying to get pregnant and
you're like wait what the [ __ ] right
no I don't blame you for that I think
when you're younger it's true if you're
like both 18 you you're like definitely
gonna get pregnant if you're [ __ ]
around when I was in Ohio we had like a
little setup with a middle school where
we would go and we would talk to them
about consent but because they taught
abstinence only
um we had to be super careful about what
we said we couldn't talk about like them
actually having sex or anything we could
only talk about like what consent meant
and like how to present it it was very
weird yeah that's bizarre I tiptoe
around it like that it's so useless they
knew exactly what we were talking about
yeah of course
yeah that's goofy well speaking of uh
jizz it's supposed to rain tonight
I was just trying to find any transition
it's supposed to rain a lot tonight
it's supposed to it's supposed to rain
especially with the information I just
found out I'm kidding
listen I'm not I'm not recommending it
maybe if you're not gonna have a kid
That's funny though I'm not listen I
think it's if you're having sex with
like a random person and your
contraceptive method is pulling out that
is [ __ ] real bad and real dumb yeah
you know what I mean like that um that
is not a good odd still just saying I
don't care how good your pullout game is
or whatever the [ __ ] that means
you have a lot of friends that learned
that the hard way there you go yeah dude
that is so crazy
maybe once yo I can't like having a baby
with some random person you don't know
or care about is like that's got to be
one of the hardest things in the world
baby will start to cry
you know and you but you probably don't
even like them as a person as
potentially and then you gotta like
be in this person's orbit forever you
have to share this person's life forever
you may not even like that dude like you
say orbit you calling them fat
wow
good catches everyone
for that one
okay here's one more story I'm gonna
wrap it up on this
um it's almost five cheating we're going
back to the try guy cheating scandal
juicy I know
I like just sitting in the audience she
Hypes me up she goes ooh I'm like oh
yeah she's giving the Ooze we need a
live audience in here with bleach hey
yeah true would you do that would you
think that would be a good idea or a
terrible idea to have a live audience
um I honestly think that'd be really I
mean it'd be fun but we're gonna do that
we're gonna go do a live show yeah the
live show but like consistently having
one here camel or a late night yeah no
that's that's a bad idea Nobody Does it
I'm saying well I'm not saying it
okay let me rephrase it's not that it's
a bad idea it's a bad idea with our
current circumstance we would need a
facility that has actually made to have
to fire code yeah that might be like a
yeah you can't you have like a hundred a
little you can't have 100 people in here
it'll be ridiculous you couldn't even
have 50 people that's true that's true
it would be pretty [ __ ] cool though
well the next building you buy that's
not it
all that [ __ ] yeah all right so back to
the try guys so
um apparently it's come out now that
uh Ned and the production person he
cheated with got caught having sex in
their car
during the day right before a video
shoot yeah right before this all hit the
fan and found out in like the craziest
way yeah it's all a legend it's not
confirmed based on context clues we are
able to come to our own conclusion so
thank you that is such a trigger word I
feel because I always hear that word
around the show too allegedly yeah
yeah before we serve any tea it's a
legend a legend it's all in Minecraft
right yeah that's you can say I like in
Minecraft better but
like I said Legend probably the lawyer
prefers that yeah term
um Ned made it perfectly easy for the
public to bust him cheating
uh due to him making out in clubs and
concerts
here he is yeah this guy didn't give a
[ __ ] it's kind of crazy how Brazen they
were again here they are making out in a
club this is how he got busted this
photo started making the rounds okay
yeah scandalous and so but what's crazy
is
this this relationship has been going on
for a while here's a picture of them
getting a lunch date back
look at these two just out and about
that's what makes me think there might
have been something more going on like
why would he feel so comfortable doing
this but well they're just having lunch
they work together it's not like that
alone isn't one on one lunch date I know
but that person who sent that picture
just now it says submitting in late so
like they probably had that yeah right
that was from yeah May of this year and
there you go so that long ago well here
is they've been even less careful than
we thought Ned's license plate was shown
in a Paparazzi video of Ned and Arielle
a few days following the che cheating
scandal a fan decided to look up his
plate and saw that his car had been
documented on an app called Nextdoor
which many of you probably know where
residents of a neighborhood air their
Grievances and basically gospel about
what's going on in the neighborhood and
they found this post that matched his
license plate this is so [ __ ] crazy
um every and so here's the post
down at the bottom it says people having
sex in a car at 5 45 while kids and
families are walking around so this
person and and he has a Tesla I saw with
that license check the Geo tag on that
make sure you clock the top Hancock Park
right that'll be important in a second
so these [ __ ] people
that's a passion I mean you can't deny
that I'm hard for it that's it I don't
know about having kids around but one or
just no bed accessible at the moment
yeah right so that's desperate yeah
desperate that's right that's right
desperate
um
so
it's been revealed that the try guys
were shooting a video in Hancock Park
that very day oops and that Alex and Ned
arrived together late
eight minutes into the video yeah
yo that [ __ ] is so crazy
Zach where are we at today we are in
Hancock Park in Los Angeles this is just
them saying so here's them eight minutes
into the video arriving together
foreign
get a load of these two they just had
sex in the [ __ ] van
that's so wild
so yeah isn't that insane no that's
horrible the fact they could put that
together I love to see a sign that's
crazy
they really plotted out like their whole
day here and then right into the video
Did anyone say for how long
um people were saying that they
had been hearing whispers for at least a
year according to Duma
but but we don't know how long actually
I mean we know it was going on for a few
months I don't know how much a legend
there was allegedly thank you just said
yeah I need you um allegedly allegedly I
appreciate your support I do I do Alex's
fiancee
Dumas reported that in September of 2021
he had found texts on her phone saying
that they had had an affair but um that
is unconfirmed
okay
what do you think about the fact that
they're not trying to make a work like
if they're going to cheat on their
significant others it'd be better if
they were trying to make it work
but then they're going back to their
other significant others that makes them
look even more pathetic
yeah and like Ned he just built an
entire house with his wife he did what
an idiot I was trying to make sure that
they didn't live in Hancock Park I'm
pretty positive because they have an
entire video detailing like their
reconstruction and remodel of their
house and I'm pretty positive it's not
in Hancock Park shooting is so dumb
you're such an idiot if you cheat it's
just such a stupid idiot thing to do
especially Ned oh my God bro it's like
worse being a public figure too
especially online where like people see
everything yes
because he wanted to [ __ ] Alex just if
you wanted her that bad you gotta
divorce bro divorce your wife yes does
Ned reference his wife in that video too
because I know he's the wife guy or
whatever
um that's a good question we should see
if he references
and if you're known for this soy face
bro you can't be walking around it doing
controversies
let's see if he mentions his wife I
might take this [ __ ] home
do the heat dude look at the grin on
their face boy we did that yeah wow my
seat is all over this place it's awesome
it's like a hotel the backyard is Lush
it's spacious it's very well appointed
the pool it's really not just a lap pool
it's a great pool for hanging and
lounging
and that [ __ ] fire pit happens to be
living in a 22 million mansion for a day
I mean they're rich I mean I don't know
if they're that rich but they're pretty
bad sex in the tree house into the pool
as people are enjoying this is my
nightmare by the way the last thing I
need is people seeing my fat ass
swimming around under the water no don't
even get me started they used a shot of
me and Ivan last season of us like half
underwater it was so bad really I hated
it is so unnecessary
wait Ivan I let wait wait wait so last
year on Paradise yeah we had like our
one-on-one date and it was like a cute
dinner thing and then they got us like
getting in the pool all you know like
sexy and unnecessary but wait why don't
I remember that yeah there was a shot of
us underwater I was like okay we didn't
need this there was a camera under the
water
yes did you know it was there no oh when
I when I saw that shot I was like wait
since when did they have cameras
underwater and they do the same thing
season two yeah everywhere don't try and
get handsy under the water they'll catch
it
right into the pool as people are
enjoying
my wife would love this house what a
great concept for a video we should make
a video similar to this you finish
should just be like living at a resort
in Hawaii for a week living at a hundred
million dollar Hotel let's go isn't that
a great video idea well it was because
it got or I guess it didn't get that I
mean 1.3 million we should we should do
a house swap where like you stay in my
condo or my apartment
I'll stay in your house I would 100 love
not to do that will you take care of my
kids too yeah I love Theodore oh my God
yeah swap lives
[Music]
no no no we're not swapping
no thank you
Pizza without me it is a funny idea I
don't hate the idea
since it's a blessings
[Music]
good watching him back now he seems like
such a douche like all the time now I'm
like this guy sucks it's crazy how like
our Championship your perception of
someone changes yeah you hear them say
do something like that totally hi guys
Shredder Alfredo besides tennis court
the lights on the tennis court here are
grandfathered in you actually can't put
lights on new tennis courts in Los
Angeles today their grandfather didn't
like wow bro yo there's lights yo
there's there's a lot of history in this
house let me tell you about the zoning
laws
I can show you all about the zoning law
I think this is like an ad for the house
that you probably got to do it for free
that's what I'm saying it's like what is
the the content is hey we go take a nice
vacation well hold on let's see it's a
dream let's read the description so
dream mansion takeover we got the tour
play in room uh yeah it's called an
Airbnb are you gonna take over looking
to work with the try guys
okay sad because a lot of realtor let's
like YouTubers yeah do tours yeah just
to promote the house and make it
interesting go up
oh okay
oh my God
welcome David
sheesh Zach the reason we have you here
is actually what's I'm looking for Ma
I need Ned shots for hair washing as
well as the hair wash I think he's in
the Tesla
go ahead
I think they're parked out front
no you deserve it
this one to keep your drink right now
where'd he go they bounced already
yeah that's a good point I'm not seeing
them in any of the shots dude get your
[ __ ] together bro a lot of bedrooms in
that Mansion
he's literally not in the video anymore
what an idiot loser
don't
forget
dude ankle dang okay okay okay
interesting
there it is
well we've been going for a long time
it's so nice to be back guys this was a
terrific uh Monday episode having too
much fun here today you think there's a
chance that I might get unbanned or you
think I mean I my feeling is that it's
permanent it's probably permanent there
was an option to appeal and I did and I
was like yo it said parody in the title
and header yeah I think I will I don't
think so yeah now that elon's the uh
he's got like a chip on his shoulder
against me
I he saw my tweets bro like I was that
[ __ ] was popping off at like 1am and I
was wondering if he was on Twitter and
he was of course he has no [ __ ] life
he got nine kids and spends more time on
Twitter than all of them combined and um
hi when the money that I saw he was
active on Twitter I knew I was gonna get
banned he saw that [ __ ]
hope so
it's always true social
yeah man truth is where it's at I need
to we need to live only to I need a
social media platform where liberals can
speak their mind and impersonate whoever
the [ __ ] they want
bring back Tumblr dude yeah Tumblr just
you're just describing Tumblr yeah well
Tumblr is bringing coming back uh
they're bringing porn back that's what I
hear so
Nature's healing
wasn't that one of the weirdest things
ever when they banned porn porn on
Tumblr exploding no porn like McDonald's
stop selling burgers yeah
that's so weird why did they do that is
this like new ownership or something
right yeah I believe uh that was a Yahoo
film the Yahoo is over at Yahoo am I
right you are right I mean if I can't
look at like a cartoon horse like
[ __ ] railing a octopus anime yeah
yeah yeah and what am I doing on on
Tumblr zootopia Amen brother yeah
exactly
man I seen more like uh furry porn on
Tumblr that shit's crazy
uh-huh love it though
it's a wild dude I love it though it was
a wild ass app
guys uh thank you to our members by the
way
um we have a members only podcast going
up tomorrow and let me tell you
introducing hold on
there's some good and bad news
the good news is there's video
introducing video yep and what costs I
saw people saying that uh they would
become a member if I did video so I said
I will do video whenever I can and I did
a video the monkey polish right here
yeah and the bad news is that the camera
that I used
recorded audio and though there's a echo
through the hole almost an hour
it's not that bad though it's listening
it's bad though like it's listenable but
it's it's quite bad to get used to it
yeah I yeah at first I was a little
concerned but it's it's not it's not too
bad yeah I don't know why it did that it
recorded desktop audio via the camera
that's never happened and I remember
even looking at OBS there was only one
sound bar
for the mic I would have to look at it
to troubleshoot it I imagine it did have
something that your camera wasn't
working and then I remote it into your
computer to help get that working again
and we got it working
um but evidently that resetting all of
that probably
yeah the audio so uh do you want to give
a little preview of what it sounds like
it's kind of funny yeah yeah yeah yeah
here one second let me pull it up well
Ela and the whole family went out like
on Sunday my family comes over took the
kids and he I was there by myself so I
sat down to record it and when I
finished and played it back I was like
man there's no way I can film this again
uh but here go ahead yeah I don't blame
you for not wanting to redo the whole
thing because it's an hour long but um
let me just take a quick listen so very
exciting
your [ __ ] Google Drive would ever
play come on
work with me work with me Google yeah
but thank you thank you to our members
um I'll be doing what's this
Ethan and brilliant
1080p definitely not 4K
yeah when Dan played earlier I'll go
what the [ __ ] is he in space this week
yeah
yeah it's a little weird sounds like a
Pink Floyd
it's a little weird but you get used to
it it is a little cursed but if you're
thinking of becoming a first time member
please sign up we got plenty of others
yeah the other ones are fine we got
behind the scenes content we got it all
right going forward we got clean audio
with video come on guys what more could
you want oh wait I'm not gonna do that
Alex Jones the people are trying to shut
me down I'm getting banned on YouTube on
and on Twitter they're trying to shut us
down folks we need all the support we
can get you need to subscribe to keep us
online folks hpodcast.com
that's right and while you're over there
your feet podcast pick on our slop
bucket it's got carrots peas
formaldehyde and asbestos
designed to stay fresh for 200 years
when the nuclear Holocaust comes you're
gonna you're gonna be happy you have
that slop bucket
[Music]
rating for dogs and humans
although also
[Music]
pick up some turmeric he just sells like
the most basic [ __ ] too we we also
bottle turmeric
good for inflammation
[Music]
yeah I don't know
um yeah so guys uh that's up thank you
to our members that's up and uh we'll be
doing video from now on guys Teddy fresh
pick up this limited time Elon Musk is a
piece of [ __ ] shirt uh for pre-order hi
a special pie especially back now to
commemorate me being banned on Twitter
thank you to Jessenia so nice to have a
guest
a guest here in the studio with us so
much fun and um you guys can look
forward to just sending a photo shoot
with Teddy fresh which is going to be
super awesome excited
and we'll have to get you back here when
you're out of contract yes totally and
we can spill all the tea yes are you
typing is there a chance you would be
doing more Paradise or is that like no
you're retiring yeah I've done three
seasons that's what Matt season
Paradise season seven and eight I'm over
it you're 30 now
dude there's some old [ __ ] on
that show
there's that okay so the one guy whose
wife passed and that's tragic and
everything super nice guy right yes
sweet but when I found out he was 38 I
was like bro you're 38 go home and be
with your kids why are you on Paradise
like you [ __ ] take a month out of
your life at 38 go home bro like he's
trying to be the he's trying to give
everyone advice you'd be like I'm like
dude you're 38. go home so I don't know
he's too old too [ __ ] old no but
that's the thing I'm like I want to kind
of get out while I'm ahead essentially
yeah yeah yeah yeah well
the franchise is going to be uh down
down a great one
and [ __ ] them and Ethan's 42 and he's
still partying I'm not I'm 37. and I'm
not going on Bachelor in Paradise for
the record my old ass that's good yeah
doesn't belong there also I'm well by
42. so maybe that guy I mean he's 38
he's got four years yeah left in him
before he even catches up with you and
then yeah it's probably 40 years
four years four years until it reaches
and
um June right record got it
yeah 37.
1937. 37 Google it okay it was in June
this year
Jordan
for everything anyways we'll be back on
a Wednesday
and Dan will be eating spicy chip baby
you [ __ ] on God and the goddamn I mean
[ __ ] can happen but unless I hook up
with a grumpy tummy
my mom is gonna call me tonight
no excuses but Wednesday is the day
all right we'll see uh all right anyway
guys thanks for watching I had a really
fun day here glad to be back here doing
our live shows love y'all
uh and [ __ ] Elon Musk there you go and
thank you Jessenia thanks all right see
you on Wednesday guys thank you
[Music]